Ich bin ein Schauspieler, der in der Zeit nicht mehr mit mir war. Ich bin ein Schauspieler, der in der Zeit nicht mehr mit mir war. Ich bin ein Schauspieler, der in der Zeit nicht mehr mit mir war.
Na, Holgi?
Wollen wir die anderen auch reinlassen?
Ja.
Wollen wir die anderen auch rein? Warte mal, wo hab ich denn Linus hingelegt?
Da ist er.
Ah, es funktioniert, super. Ja, ich hab irgendwie die falschen Reglerbelegungen. Guten Abend, hier ist das Chaosradio 189, ne? 189, im Studio Konstanze? Na, der Linus? Hallo. Und der Nibbler, hast du einen Kopfhörer? Ach, den schäbigen von immer.
Den billigen.
Ach Mensch, ich hab die Unterlegemusik vergessen. Da hatten sich ja einige doch darüber beschwert, dass immer Unterlegmusik läuft. Wollen wir die heute spielen oder wollen wir's lassen?
Ich bin ja dagegen, nur wegen der vielen Zuschriften.
Ups, aber es ist eine ganz schöne Unterlegmusik. Guck mal, der Linus auch am Grufen.
Nein, nein, nein.
Linus hat kein Mikro.
Ach so, weil da jetzt Musik drauf läuft. Bevor wir ins Thema einsteigen, der Newsflash.
Ja, wir wollten, bevor wir heute über Drosselkomm reden und das funktional kaputte Internet.
Funktional kaputt.
Dann wollten wir ein bisschen ein News Update machen. Denn Linus war für den CCC gleich zweimal im Bundestag und hat versucht, die Politiker zu beraten. Mitten da, sagen wir mal, durchgewachsen im Erfolg. Und will mal ein bisschen berichten über die Anhörung zur Die-E-Mail. Also, das war wenigstens mal so fünf Minuten Update machen.
Ja, es ging konkret um das E-Government und das E-Justice-Gesetz, zu dem ich einmal im Innenausschuss des Bundestags war und dann einmal im Justizausschuss des Bundestages. Und im Innenausschuss ging es um das E-Government-Gesetz. Das heißt eigentlich das Gesetz zur Förderung der elektronischen Verwaltung oder so des Bundespippa-Po.
Wachstumsbeschleunigungsgesetz.
Telekom-Wachstumsbeschleunigungsgesetz.
Und da ging es hauptsächlich darum, dass man sagt, man möchte irgendwie diese gesamten Behördenkram mal in dieses digitale Zeitalter heben. Und aus verschiedenen Gründen haben sie natürlich erkannt, dass so die normale E-Mail da nicht unbedingt das ideale Medium ist. Und schon vor ein paar Jahren, übrigens jetzt stört mich die Hintergrundmusik doch durchaus, ja.
Ich hab so schöne Mixer ausgesucht.
Haben sie sich dann entschieden?
Soll ich ein bisschen lauter machen? Ist dann vielleicht ein bisschen groovier? Ich.
Du musst doch den Linus mal ausreden.
Entschuldigung, aber wenn ich schon meine Musik nicht hören darf, dann kann ich wenigstens ins Wort fallen.
Zu den Unzulänglichkeiten der E-Mail gibt es ja schon seit einigen Jahren dann Lösungen, diese Unzulänglichkeiten zu begegnen. Also mangelnde Verschlüsselung der Kommunikation über E-Mail. Dafür haben wir dann E-Mail Verschlüsselungen entwickelt. Und mangelnde Zuordnung der E-Mail zu ihrem Absender. Der wollte dann das BSI mit einem Vorschlag entgegentreten, dass man sagt, man macht eine D-Mail. Und diese D-Mail ist das gleiche System, noch mal parallel zur E-Mail gebaut. Funktioniert aber nicht kompatibel dazu. Man erfindet die E-Mail einfach noch mal neu.
So eine Insellösung, sowas wie...
Ach so, ich dachte, das wäre eine besonders verschlüsselte E-Mail. Also so, dass ich mit meinem PGP-Clicky-Bunti, was ich mittlerweile zu Hause auch habe...
Sowas wie MSN Messenger nur anders.
Da merke ich ja sogar ich, dass die bescheuert sind.
Das ist doch total absurd, warum macht man denn sowas? Wir erfinden die E-Mail noch mal neu. Aber warum macht man sowas? Also...
Geschäftsmodell?
Es ist natürlich in der Realisierung, wie es jetzt stattgefunden hat, ein Geschäftsmodell für die großen Anbieter.
Außer den Post, die hat da schon keine Lust mehr drauf.
Die haben ja auch den E-Post-Brief.
Post hat den E-Post-Brief und hat jetzt direkt eine Beschwerde gegen das E-Government-Gesetz vor der EU-Kommission angestrengt, weil sie da nicht mit glücklich waren mit dem Weg, den dieses Gesetz gegangen ist. Letztendlich, klar, es ging darum, wir irgendwie bekämpfen mehrere Makel der E-Mail. Unter anderem, dass sie so für eine rechtssichere Kommunikation nicht taugt. Taugt? Taugt? Taugt? Und dass sie kostenlos ist. Das wollen wir natürlich auch nicht mehr. Deswegen schreiben wir jetzt einfach mal einen Geldbetrag dran, den so eine D-Mail dann kostet. Weil wir wissen ja alle, was nichts kostet, ist auch nichts. Und deshalb schreiben wir Preis dran und damit ist das dann was.
Haben die schon so eine Preisvorstellung genannt?
Ich meine, das waren 55 Cent oder so. Oder waren das 75 sogar? Ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
Allein die Klagen, also pro Zustellung.
Das wird dann auch in Anführungszeichen rechtssichere nicht zugestellt. Also du musst dein E-Mail postfach, wenn du dir eins zulegst, auch regelmäßig abrufen, weil da sonst irgendwelche Zustellungen von Gericht und so weiter drin liegen können, die dann tatsächlich auch als zugestellt gelten.
So ist es.
Das fühlt sich ein bisschen so an, als wäre in spätestens zehn Jahren, wäre das Pflicht, dass du das zu deiner Steuernummer dazu bekommst.
Das ist in diesen Gesetzen im Prinzip jetzt schon Pflicht. Das ist im Moment, mit dem jetzt gerade beschlossenen E-Government-Gesetz, die einzige zulässige Kommunikationsform für so ganzen Kram, was weiß ich, was man an Behördengängen zum Beispiel digital erledigen würde.
Gerichtskommunikation.
Gerichtskommunikation dann auch, das war der zweite Teil. Mein Hauptkritikpunkt an der D-Mail ist, dass wir keine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung haben. Das heißt, die D-Mail wird nicht auf meinem Rechner verschlüsselt, sodass nur der Empfänger sie entschlüsseln kann, sondern sie wird von mir verschlüsselt an meinen D-Mail-Provider gesendet. Der macht dann dort einen Virenscan, damit das Ganze auch schön sicher ist.
Also er macht sie nochmal auf, die Mail, dekodiert?
Er dekodiert sie, macht einen Virenscan.
Und das betrachten die als sichere Behördenkommunikation? Das ist doch völlig absurd.
Dann stell dir vor, wenn das ein Postwesen der Fall wäre, dann könnte niemand mehr Briefbomben durch die Gegend checken.
Zumindest überlegen wir, wie sicher das wäre.
Wenn die Post dir das Paket aufmachen würde, dann nochmal reingucken.
Außer es steht Amazon drauf, weil dann würden die nämlich den Euro oder hat sich ein Buch bestellt.
Der Unterschied ist, dass man ja üblicherweise als Webmer nicht bezahlen möchte. Die E-Mail ist da ein kostenträchtiger Service. Insofern, wie viel Webner so bekommt, wir werden sehen.
Man muss natürlich auch irgendwie so einen Mehrwert bieten und irgendwie erklären, warum das sicher ist. Aber nicht nur wird die E-Mail dann erst auf dem Server meines Providers geöffnet und auf Viren untersucht. Nein, dort wird sie dann auch für mich unterschrieben.
Von deinem Provider?
Von meinem Provider?
Dem gegenüber, du dich wie identifizierst?
Ich hab ihm ja beim Eröffnen mal meinen Ausweis gezeigt.
Zum Beispiel deinen neuen Personalausweis.
Ich habe ihm ja beim Eröffnen des Kontes meinen Ausweis gezeigt. Und wenn ich die sichere Anmeldung wähle, dann habe ich ja auch eine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung gemacht. Also ich habe eine M-TAN auf mein Mobiltelefon bekommen. Und deswegen kann er ja dann für mich unterschreiben. Ist ja klar, kein Problem. So zumindest die Ansicht der anderen Herren Sachverständigen oder einiger der Sachverständigen, die auch dort im Justizausschuss waren.
Was ich nicht verstehe ist, das sind Sachverständige und selbst ich merke, dass das Unfug ist, was du mir da gerade erzählst.
Das merken die selber auch.
Aber deren Kernargumentation ist, wir haben bisher Faxe akzeptiert.
Das war auch die letzten zehn Jahre der Witz an der Sache, ihr Idioten.
Ich habe versucht, das ein bisschen gewählter zu machen.
Darum konnten wir immer so schön unsere Unterschriften scannen, irgendjemandem mailen und der hat dann mal schnell einen Fax geschickt.
Aber jetzt unterschreibt die Telekom. Ja, super. Also T-Systems bzw. die Deutsche Telekom für Privatanwender.
Die sozusagen dann den Hunderter- Tausenderpack Vollmachten rumliegen hat und für die ein Bürger unterschreiben darf.
Das ist natürlich auch für Hacker jetzt ein überhaupt ein sehr uninteressantes Angriffsziel.
Ja, völlig.
Ein Server, von dem ich halt potenziell für viele Bundesbürger rechtsverbindliche Kommunikation abwickeln kann.
Zum Beispiel mit dem Grundbuchamt oder was braucht man um Großzügigkeit?
Verträge, die in bestimmten Rechtsformen bedürfen. Also da wird ein interessantes, lohnendes Ziel.
Also irgendwie sollte man aus Hacker sich das gar nicht verhindern, sondern sich darüber freuen, dass sie ja so ein Hacker-Ermächtigungsgesetz...
Wir haben aber diese Hacker-Ethik, Nübler.
Arschhals drauf, ich geb dir nen 50er, komm.
Also was heißt das jetzt? Im Prinzip heißt das, also ich glaube, meine Theorie zu dem Entstehen ist, dass man sich irgendwann mal im Innenministerium gedacht hat, das wär eventuell nicht besonders günstig, wenn wir in unserem Land jetzt eine Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Kommunikationsform einführen, wo im Moment der Grad der verschlüsselten E-Mails unter 10% liegt. Wenn wir jetzt auf einmal den Leuten sagen, hier habt ihr eine Kommunikationsform, die wir selber nicht abhören können.
Glaubst du, dass sie so weit denken? Das glaubst du nicht wirklich.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die, also einen anderen Grund gibt es nicht dafür, das so falsch zu machen, obwohl es seit 20 Jahren ja die Verfahren gibt, um verschlüsselte unsignierte Kommunikation Ende zu Ende ernsthaft durchzuführen.
Ja, was ich eigentlich von meiner Regierung erwarte, ist, dass die mir endlich Plug-ins für alle gängigen Mail-Programme zur Verfügung stellen.
Muss ich noch nicht schon rausgeben für andere Dinge.
Da gibt es übrigens das ganz schön. Die D-Mail wird dann so über Web gemacht.
Und Freunde von mir haben so ein Ding, so ein PIDA heißt das, ich weiß nicht, ob du da mal drüber gestolpert bist, pida.com. Das verschlüsselt im Browser deine Kommunikation und das ist eigentlich ganz gut, glaube ich. Ja genau, und Identitätsverwaltung und sowas alles. Aber das ist nicht das, was die meinen mit...
Das Problem ist ja auch, dass Browser einfach mal nicht sicher sind, ist so. Also es gibt irgendwie regelmäßig da Probleme und wir sind weit davon entfernt, dass man einem Browser auch noch mal entfernt das trauen kann. Und wenn dann in solchen Ausschüssen Leute, also Politiker anfangen und so zählen, ja, wie ist das denn dann, wenn ich aus dem Internetcafé im Urlaub meine D-E-Mail... Du lachst.
Das haben die mich ja gefragt.
Lass uns mal kurz sagen, wer hat es und mit welcher Fragestellung eigentlich an dich gerichtet?
Der FDP-Bundestagsabgeordnete Manuel Höferlin hat zum einen... Wie alt ist der?
108?
Nee, der wird so alt nicht sein.
Vielleicht so 33 oder 35?
Ich hab ja dann im Innenausschuss gesagt, Freunde, ihr müsst das Ende zu Ende machen, dann habt ihr ein ordentliches System hier, da könnt ihr wirklich mal auch international mit nach vorne treten und sagen, hier, da haben wir was ordentliches gemacht für unsere Jürger. Und dann sagte er, ja, wenn ich jetzt im Urlaub in der Türkei in ein Internetcafé gehe und möchte dann meine D-Mail abholen, wie mache ich das denn dann mit den Zertifikaten, die ich ja dann brauche, um die zu lesen, bei einer Ende zu Ende verschmissen?
Er hat das wirklich gefragt.
Und dann habe ich ihm erklärt, dass ich ihm nicht dazu raten würde, das zu tun.
Selbst ich, selbst ich habe einen separaten Mail-Account, den ich in Internetcafés benutze, damit ich meine normale Kommunikation gar nicht über ein... Wo war das Internetcafé?
Das ist ja völlig egal. Aber sie haben gesagt, das ist in der Türkei.
Ja, damit ich meine normale Kommunikation, die mir irgendwas bedeutet, gar nicht erst über dieses Internetcafé routen muss.
Also du willst ja unter keinen Umständen... Und dann wurde aber betont, dass es das Ziel der D-Mail ist, dass man das mobil machen kann. Ich finde das ja einen tollen Sprung von... Also muss man jetzt mal aus deren Perspektive sehen. Es ist ja ein toller Sprung von irgendwie zwei Stunden anstehen, um einen verlorenen Führerschein neu zu beantragen, zu in der Türkei im Urlaub seinen Führerschein verlieren und mal kurz über D-Mail, über ein Internetcafé einen neuen Führerschein beantragen. Das zeigt aber halt auch, wer dann da alles Führerscheine für dich beantragen will.
Wir machen einfach einen Internetcafé in der Türkei auf, oder? Ist das kompatibel mit der Hacker-Ethik denn?
Manuel Löferlin hat noch einen draufgesetzt. Nachdem er so Linus erklärt hat, also gab er noch so ein bisschen hin und zurück und Nachfragen, war ja Linus ein zweites Mal diesmal im Rechtsausschuss. Da hat er exakt dieselbe Frage noch mal gestellt.
Nur zu Signaturen, ja.
Kann es sein, dass er diese Frage stellt, damit du antworten kannst, das ist vollkommen absurd? Also kann es sein, dass er wieder einen roten Teppich ausrollt?
Er möchte... Er stellt mir diese Frage, um mich zu der Aussage zu bewegen, dass ein Ende-zu-Ende verschlüsseltes, sichereres System einen Mehraufwand für den Nutzer bedeutet.
Und in einem unsicheren Umfeld genauso wenig funktioniert wie... Wie alles andere. Naja, die E-Mail würde dann da ja funktionieren, aber es wäre halt nicht sicher. Das ist ja egal, solange da nichts passiert. Ich glaube, ich kaufe ein E und möchte lösen. Ding ding ding, beratungsresistent.
Also ich hab... Warum? Habt ihr den mal hinterher recherchiert? Also hat der irgendwie geschäftliche Verbindungen zu denjenigen, die an die E-Mail verdienen werden oder sowas?
Nein, ich glaube, das ist auch schlicht die Koalitionslinie. Man will durchbringen, diese merkwürdige Totgeburt von der E-Mail. Wenn man die Kunden, die sich da registriert haben, bisher sind da sehr wenige. Es hat nicht wirklich geflogen. Und jetzt ist halt die Idee, was man in andere Rechtsgebiete...
Solange die mich da nicht dazu zwingen, werde ich doch einen Teufel tun, sowas zu benutzen.
Du solltest da keinen Umständen machen. Du hast nur Nachteile dadurch. Du hast ein unsicheres Kommunikationsmedium. Du musst die Scheißdinger abholen. Und zwar irgendwie alle drei Tage, weil die gelten als zugestellt.
Jemand anders unterzeichnet sie für dich.
Jemand anders unterschreibt sie für dich. Und du hast natürlich, habe ich den ja im Justizausschuss gerade versucht zu erklären, wenn mein Account da gehackt wird und jemand da eine Willensbekundung tätigt und wer Gesetz steht, das gilt als signiertes Dokument. Und die Beweislast liegt auf mir, zu zeigen, dass mein Account gehackt wurde. Und als Normalbürger habe ich gar keine Möglichkeit. Gar keine Möglichkeit. Das heißt, ich habe da eine automatische Hintertür. Ich müsste ewig besorgt sein, dass jemand Waschmaschinen kauft oder so.
Im besten Fall, weil da hast du wenigstens noch ein Rückgaberecht. Was ist, wenn du Immobilien anfängst zu kaufen oder Steuererklärungen machen? Ich kann dir dann mal eine Steuererklärung über anderthalb Millionen für dich machen. Und dann kannst du dem Finanzamt nachweisen, dass du nur 150.000 oder 15.000 verdient hast.
Das ist verkacken im industriellen Maßstab, wie wir es bei Tollcollect schon gesehen haben. Und das wird genauso ein Desaster werden.
Ich möchte mal was Positives sagen, wenn man das hier nicht so negativ anfängt.
Erdbeerkuchen.
Hey, die DEM-Anbieter müssen sich zertifizieren lassen.
Ja, das kostet ein Schweine Geld.
Moment, Anbieter im Sinne von DEM, dir als Kunden. Also die Signierer.
Da gibt es einen sehr, sehr vielen Seiten umfassenden Katalog vom BSI, Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik. Und da musst du überall ein grünes Häkchen haben. Und dann darfst du DEM-Anbieter sein. Ein Teil dieses Konzeptes wurde jetzt in Reaktionen um die Aufregung um DEM-Mail dann auch mal gezeigt. Da gab es also, das ist ein sehr schöner Artikel, den man da lesen kann auf Heise, wo dann Journalisten eingeladen wurden von der Deutschen Telekom, sich doch mal anzuschauen, wie sicher die DEM-Mail ist. Und man fing an mit dem Hohenzauen-Umsrechenzentrum. Und dann wurde gesagt, wenn man durch diesen Zaun ist, dann muss man noch mal durch drei Türen mit Vereinzelung schleusen.
Und da bringen wir mal einen USB-Stick durch, die Dinger sind nämlich so groß.
Und vor dem Gebäude kommt dann, also zwischen Zaun und Gebäude, kommen dann noch mal so Perimeterschütze gegen angreifende Bulldozer. Du hörst ja immer wieder, wie die Hacker mit dem Bulldozer durch den Perimeterschutz brettern.
Gefühlt Sicherheit über 9000.
Was ich so krass finde, ist eigentlich, ich hab vor 12 oder 13 Jahren das erste Mal in meinem Leben ein Chaosradio gemacht. Und es hat sich nichts geändert, nichts. Das hat sich nichts geändert.
Hat sich was geändert, Holgi.
Es hat sich nichts geändert. Genau diese Geschichte hätte Linus mir vor 13 Jahren erzählen können. Nur mit anderen, also nicht mit D-Mail, sondern mit, was weiß ich, Gesundheitskarte.
Aber da hat sich nichts geändert. Und das erste ist, die Parteien haben jetzt alle netzpolitische Sprecher.
Das hat sich geändert.
Und wir haben Flatwraiths. Noch.
Und wir haben den EPA.
Und wir haben eine aktive Netzöffentlichkeit. Hey. Gut, wir wollen mal, glaube ich, die E-Mail abschließen. Wir wollten nur mal aktuell berichten von Linus Erdebnissen.
Also haben die dazu gesagt, wie tief die in die Verwaltung eindringen wollen mit demail?
Also du kriegst heute nichts mehr. Kein E-Government, E-Justice oder sonst was. Vorstoß irgendwo mehr am BMI oder BMJ vorbei, ohne dass die E-Mail drin steht. Und das ist einfach eine ganz klare Wirtschaftsförderung, die jetzt stattfindet. Durch was anderes ist so ein Bullshit einfach nicht zurechtfertig.
Wir können sie abwählen. Ist doch halt wieder Wahl.
Ja, aber...
Okay, wir müssen uns mal abschließen, Männer. Wir haben heute eigentlich draus gekommen als Thema.
Das ist heute so.
Auf dem Weg hier hin? Ich will gar nicht.
Magst du mal die Hotline anrufen?
Was?
Die Hotline anrufen.
Ich ruf mal die Hotline an.
Wir reden aber jetzt noch nicht über Drosselkomm.
Wir haben noch ein Thema? Dann mach ich das einfach, dann mach ich wieder die Unterlegmusik an. Wir haben noch ein aktuelles Thema?
Es wartet noch eine Person vor Ihnen.
Tatsächlich, noch ein Thema vorne.
Wir hatten ja gestern eine Urteilsverkündung in Karlsruhe. Gestern ist ja die Urteil zur Anti-Terror-Datei ergangen. Wenigstens wollen wir mal kurz darüber berichten. Das Presseecho war ja so ein bisschen geteilt. Aber ich will mal wenigstens zusammenfassen, was das Gericht in Karlsruhe eigentlich gesagt hat. Also im Wesentlichen ist erstmal die Message, die Anti-Terror-Datei ist zumindest teilen verfassungsgemäß. Und nur einige Teile wurden als verfassungswidrig gebrannt, die ist also gerade noch hinnehmbar, wenn man so sagen will. Aber mit einigen Einschränkungen. Und die betreffen vor allen Dingen die Menschen, die dort aufgenommen werden dürfen. Das sind ja derzeit so um die 17.000 Personen. Und gerade der Teil der Kontaktpersonen sind, also Menschen, die nicht direkt verdächtigt werden.
Also alle, die den Bärtigen mal ein Brötchen verkauft haben.
Unter die Kollegen und die Nachbarn. Da sind sehr viel strengere Regeln aufgenommen worden. Dann hat man neue oder man hat konkretisiert, wie es mit diesen sogenannten verdeckten Dateien ist. Dann gibt es Grunddaten, die man einsehen kann. Und Teil von verdeckten Daten, die man nicht unmittelbar abrufen kann. Also sie haben sich tatsächlich sehr kleinteilig um die einzelnen Regelungen im Gesetz gekümmert. Aber es gibt auch ein paar fundamental neue Grundsätze. Nämlich zum einen, dass das BKA eine Art Transparenzbericht machen muss. Und zwar auch einen, der aussagekräftig ist. Das heißt, die müssen darüber berichten, wie häufig auf diese Datei zugegriffen wurde. Und wie viele Personen darin gespeichert wurden und solche Daten. Immerhin, wir reden hier...
Wem müssen die darüber berichten?
Der Öffentlichkeit.
Also nicht irgendein geheimer Kontrolleinschluss.
Na auch die Kontrollbehörden wurden gestärkt. Man hat sogar ganz klare Regierungen in dem Beurteil, dass die vielen, wir reden hier über ein paar Millionen Transaktionsdaten, also so Logdaten, dass die auch in einer Weise den Behörden zur Verfügung gestellt werden müssen, also den Prüfbehörden, dass die auch verarbeitbar sind, also sprich digital. Und die Landes- und Bundesdatenschutzbehörden dürfen hier zusammenarbeiten, denn in dieser Datei arbeiten ja auch die Ermittlungsbehörden zusammen. Zu dem eigentlichen Knackpunkt, wo sie glaube ich viele Leute gewünscht haben, dass da mehr kommt, nämlich zum Trennungsgebot, da hat das Gericht leider noch nicht die Notbremse gezogen, die sich viele gewünscht haben. Man muss ja sehen, dass die Aufgaben der Geheimdienste und Polizeien sehr unterschiedlich sind. Also die einen sammeln Informationen den ganzen Tag. Wir wissen auch nicht wieso. Und die anderen sind natürlich als Ermittlungsbehörden schon auch mal präventiv tätig. Aber im Wesentlichen werden sie ja tätig, um Verbrecher zu fangen oder Verbrechen zu verhindern. Und diese Aufgaben sind natürlich durch die Datei jetzt gemischt. Und da hat zumindest Gericht nicht wirklich eine scharfe Grenze gezogen. Man muss das informell trennen, also informationell trennen. Aber ich glaube, viele haben sich doch ein bisschen mehr gewünscht. Mich persönlich hat das Urteil eher enttäuscht, denn die so typische Sicherheitshysterie und auch das Wording, also die Sprache, die ist ja schon drin bis hin zur Schutzlücke.
Schutzlücke war das, genau. Es gab einen sehr interessanten Artikel, ich glaube von Kai Biermann war der in der Zeit. Zeit online, genau. Zeit online, genau. Der ist auch so gut geschrieben, den kann ich auch meinen Eltern zeigen und sie verstehen, was das Problem ist und das ist ganz angenehm da dran.
Ja, also Thomas Darnstedt hatte auf Spohnen auch noch glaube ich eine ziemlich kurzfristige gute Einschätzung. Also ich teile da eher so ein bisschen die Skepsis. Ich glaube, viele hätten sich mehr gewünscht. Und nicht nur um diese Datei, sondern auch andere Dateien, die nach diesem Vorbild aufgebaut sind. Müssen wir mal sehen. Also mir ist in diesem Urteil viel zu sehr betont, wie sehr diese Sicherheitsideologie auch die Begründung dominiert. Also Terrorismus sei halt so eine große Gefahr, dass man dort Einschnitte hinnehmen müsse. Aber die Definition, was Terror sein soll, also unter welchem Maßgaben man in dieser Datei landen kann, die bleibt halt schwammig. Also war so ein bisschen enttäuschend, aber auch gleichzeitig nicht nur, weil natürlich ein paar harte Grenzen gezogen wurden.
Kannst du noch mal so zusammenfassen, was deine Hauptkritikpunkte an der Anti-Terror-Datei überhaupt sind?
Also ich glaube, die meisten Kritikpunkte betreffen zum einen die sehr große Anzahl von Menschen. Also ich meine, zu argumentieren, dass wir hier 17.000 Terrorverdächtige hätten, also grenzt das schon an Real-Sattire. Dann natürlich die finturische Frage. Man muss ja legalistisch irgendwie festlegen, was ist Terror, was ist Gewalt, was ist Gewalt unterstützendes Verhalten. Und diese Begriffe sind halt nach wie vor sehr schwammig.
Das heißt, das liegt dann wahrscheinlich im Ermessen irgendwelcher Beamter, oder?
Das ist eine Auslegungsfrage und es sind halt auch sehr viele Behörden, die dort zwangsweise die Daten eintragen. Denn man muss quasi die eigenen Datensätze danach auswählen, ob dort Tafelverdächtige gespeichert sind und die in einer Zentralstelle beim BKA hinterlegen, in einem standardisierten Format. Und es gab halt, da gibt es ein paar Kennzeichen, die dort gespeichert werden, die ich für sehr kritisch halte. Das ist die Religionszugehörigkeit. Also Glaubensbekenntnis ist auch nicht weiter thematisiert worden. Früher wäre das aus meiner Sicht, man kann über Religion denken, ob man will.
Aber das ist ja das, was wir jetzt sehen.
Aber das war diesmal nicht so. Und aus meiner Sicht ist das natürlich technisch zu wenig betrachtet worden. Wir wissen, dass viele Dateien oder Datensätze nicht unbedingt inländischen Ursprungs sind.
Hier gibt es gerade im Geheimdienstbereich einen Regen Datenhandel, da sind in Guantanamo aus jemandem rausgeworded worden, was in unserer Anti-Terror-Datei steht.
Ich weiß halt nicht genau, ob dieser Murat Kurnas und Al Maasri Fall so kurz im öffentlichen Gedächtnis sind, dass das wieder vergessen wurde.
Ja, natürlich, das hat keiner mitgekriegt.
Also ich bin da doch ein bisschen erstaunt, dass hier nicht härter durchgegriffen wurde. Aber mir scheint auch, dass so ein bisschen diese Boston, dieser Marathonsprengsatz sicherlich auch nochmal dazu beigetragen hat, dass man sich auch nicht traut, hier diesem Sicherheitsdenken entgegenzusetzen. Ich finde das sehr schade.
Trennungsgebot?
Ja, das Trennungsgebot ist nicht so direkt bei uns im Grundgesetz.
Ich meine, das Trennungsgebot zwischen Polizei und Geheimdiensten, ja oder? Ja, weil Staat und Kirche ist auch...
Lass mich doch mal trollen. Ich darf schon meine Unterlegmusik nicht spielen.
Mich wunderst du, weil du es jetzt nicht noch mal mitnannt hast unter den entscheidenden Gründen, warum du dagegen doch warst.
Das Gericht hat schon sehr deutlich ausgeführt, dass die Aufgaben der Geheimdienste und Polizeien sehr unterschiedlich sind und hat auch klar gemacht, dass die Geheimdienste im Grunde keine klaren gesetzlichen Vorgaben haben, für die Datensammellnlei auch sehr viel schlechter kontrolliert sind und dass die Polizeien eben viel deutlichere gesetzliche Vorgaben haben, die viel präziser sind und dass sie natürlich auf eine andere Weise dadurch, dass sie die Informationen, die sie sammeln, ja dem, der beschuldigt wird, irgendwann, zumindest im Regelfall, zur Kenntnis geben, einfach wenn er vor Gericht kommt zum Beispiel, dass es hier große Unterschiede gibt, qualitativ. Dennoch betrachten sie diesen Ansatz als hinnehmbar. Darüber kann man sich natürlich streiten. Die Beschwerde, also der Beschwerdeführer und sein Anwalt, sein Sohn, die waren nicht unzufrieden. Also die waren schon durchaus, haben sehr viele Punkte, die sie eben beklagt haben, ja auch durchgekriegt.
Wer war das?
Das ist ein ehemaliger Richter, der heißt Sürmann und sein Sohn, der ihn als Anwalt vertreten hat.
Verstehe.
Man muss auch mal sagen, also die Datei, die existiert seit 2006, ist der einzige Mensch, der sich auf den Weg nach Karlsruhe gemacht hat, um dort Verfassungsbeschwerde einzudrücken.
Die anderen haben es dann nicht mitgekriegt, ne?
Man muss schon sagen, man sollte dem auch Tribut zollen, dass dort jemand macht, das ist ja auch viel Arbeit und sich traut und ich kann verstehen, dass er sich darüber gefreut hat, bei mir war das so ein bisschen Schalenbeigeschmack. Ich hätte mir irgendwie ein bisschen mehr gewünscht.
Ja, du tust ja immer.
Also ich glaube die technische Entwicklung auch in den Tools, mit denen diese Daten dazu bearbeitet werden, die macht natürlich Sprünge, aber das Gericht hat hier gesagt, eine Rastewunk oder eine Invers-Suche auf den Daten sei definitiv nicht erlaubt, also immerhin sind hier.
Sie werden es halt trotzdem tun.
Wir hoffen, dass die neuen Prüfmöglichkeiten, die wir hören, wohl auch genutzt werden.
Ich hab die Tage erzählt, die ich noch von einem Freund von mir, der war mal Polizist und ist aus dem Dienst ausgeschieden wieder, der hat gesagt, ich mach das nicht mehr mit, nachdem er ein paar Jahre observiert hat. Und der hat dann halt mal bei mir, hat er halt gerne mal erzählt, wie es da wirklich gelaufen ist und was von diesen ganzen Sachen, dass dieser absolut geschützte Intimbereich und sowas, dass da nicht abgehört werden dürfte und sowas. Er hat auch gesagt, ja, kannst du doch vergessen halt. Und der hat halt genau deswegen den Dienst quittiert, was ich schon sehr, sehr nobel finde. Zu sagen, nee, ich mach was anderes, ich mach den Scheiß, das mach ich nicht mehr mit.
Bleiben aber nur Leute übrig, die den Kernbereich der privaten Lebensführung nicht sonderlich schätzen.
Das ist der juristische Begriff für die Intimsphäre.
Ja, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie es hieß.
Ja, die bleiben über. Die anderen gehen nicht in den Bereich.
Die anderen gehen.
Naja, also natürlich.
Wie bei jedem anderen Job auch.
Genau.
Also ich finde es halt schade, dass die sicherlich aus dem Urteil auch wieder in eine Neuregelung, die sie jetzt bis Dezember 2014 treffen müssen, sicherlich auch wieder kopieren werden. Denn die Richter haben wiederum Möglichkeiten aufgezeigt, wie man es dann anders machen könnte. Das wird sicherlich wieder geschehen. Ich wollte wenigstens mal aus Karlsruhe berichten.
Ich hätte noch eine Frage zum Sachverständigen, den sie im Ausschuss anlien. Du gehst dahin, du erklärst denen das und merkst, die entweder wollen sie es nicht begreifen, können es nicht begreifen oder sonst was. Amüsiert dich das oder frustriert dich das?
Wir haben da gerade schon mal kurz beim Essen drüber gesprochen. Ich nehme solche Themen ein bisschen zu ernst, um mich da einfach so spöttisch drüber zu amüsieren. Ich kann mir einen Teil meiner Frustration dadurch nehmen, dass ich mit ein paar Leuten drüber lache. Insgesamt halte ich das für eine relativ tragische Angelegenheit und frustrierend finde ich dann, und derjenige weiß genau Bescheid, wenn die Leute dann nachher am Fahrstuhl zu mir kommen, die mir in der Anhörung entgegentreten und mir am Fahrstuhl nach der Anhörung sagen, ich weiß ja, dass sie Recht haben. Da habe ich halt keinen Bock drauf. Wir haben da gerade drüber gesprochen, kann man jetzt hin und her, aber die sind halt auf Koalitionslinien. Die wissen, dass ich Recht habe, aber die wissen halt, dass es in einer Fraktion anders aussieht und meinen dann noch einen auf gut Freund nach dem Gefecht machen zu müssen. Das nimmt mir dann ehrlich gesagt den Spaß.
Die netzpolitischen Sprecher wissen schon, dass ihre Macht begrenzt ist, wenn es gegen die Koalitionslinie oder Fraktionslinie geht.
Gleichzeitig wäre es natürlich auch ein schöner Scoop, wenn sie sich mal gegen die Fraktionslinie stellen würden. Damit ständen sie dann auf allen Titelseiten.
Das schafft nicht Marosula von allein.
Ich bin doch ihre Kollegen nicht mit Realität verwirrend.
Stimmt, ihr hattet Chaosradio 189, das war unser Newsflash und gleich geht's weiter mit der Telekom, da müssen wir jetzt aber erstmal warten.
In unserer Reihe Künstler beim Wort genommen, jetzt! Samstag, 3. August. Live und Open Air in der Berliner Waldbühne. So lange es noch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten überall wo es Karten gibt. Live in Berlin und Sommer.
Präsentiert von Fritz.
Immer gute neue.
Meteonte Weiland.
Die Betreiber des künftigen Flughafens BER in Schönefeld müssen die Anwohner besser vor Fluglärm schützen als bisher geplant. Das entschied das Oberverwaltungsgericht Berlin Brandenburg am Abend. Weil das Schallschutzprogramm des Flughafens zu klein bemessen ist, kommen auf den Flughafen jetzt mehr Kosten in Höhe von rund 300 Millionen Euro zu. In dem Verfahren ging es darum, ob Fluglärm tagsüber die normale Gesprächslautstärke von 55 Dezibel in den 14.000 betroffenen Wohnungen überschreiten darf. An den Berliner Schulen könnte im Mai wieder gestreikt werden. Nach RBB-Information ist die Tarifkommission der Gewerkschaft GEW dafür, dass die Lehrer Mitte Mai eine Woche nicht arbeiten. Das letzte Wort hat am Montag der Landesvorstand der GEW. Bereits am Dienstag gab es in Berlin einen Warnstreik. Die Gewerkschaft will erreichen, dass Angestellte und verbeamtete Lehrer vergleichbar bezahlt werden. Das Land ist weltweit der zweitwichtigste Hersteller von Kleidung. Die mutmaßlichen Attentäter von Boston sollen auch einen Anschlag auf den Times Square in New York geplant haben. Bürgermeister Bloomberg sagte, dies habe ihm die Bundespolizei FBI mitgeteilt. Die beiden Brüder hätten dafür bereits Bomben gebaut. Sie werden für die Anschläge vom 15. April auf den Boston Marathon verantwortlich gemacht, bei dem drei Menschen starben und über 250 verletzt wurden. Einer der beiden wurde von der Polizei getötet, der andere liegt verletzt im Krankenhaus.
Wetter.
Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen. In Berlin Köpenick haben wir es 12, in Tempelhof 17 Grad. Forst meldet 11, Eberswalde 14, Potsdam 16 und Wittenberge 17 Grad. In der Nacht kühlt es auf 13 bis 9 Grad ab, nur in Richtung Norden gibt es dichtere Wolken und hier dann auch vereinzelt Regen. Morgen zeigt sich dann erst die Sonne, später ziehen dichtere Wolken heran und neben Regen gibt es örtlich auch Gewitter, das Ganze dann bei maximal 18 Grad an der Dosse und 26 Grad an der Neiße. Verkehr Berlin A100 stattdringen Richtung Neukölln zwischen Hohenzolland am und Tunnel Innsbrucker Platz ist wegen einer Baustelle die linke Spur gesperrt. A113 Zubringer Schönefeld statt einwärts zwischen Schönefeld Nord und Adlershof gibt es eine Vollsperrung wegen Wartungsarbeiten. Das Ganze dauert noch bis 5 Uhr früh. Und auf der AWUS A115 sind die Auf- und Abfahrten in den Hüttenweg bis Ende Mai in beiden Richtungen gesperrt. Gesperrt ist außerdem der Hüttenweg unter der Bahnbrücke. Dann nach Brandenburg, Art 10 westlicher Berliner Ringen Richtung Dreieck Werder. Zwischen Spandau und Potsdam Nord ist die rechte Spur blockiert. Hier liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn. Fahrt hier also bitte vorsichtig. Und A24 Berlin Richtung Hamburg. Zwischen Dreieck Haveland und Kremn gibt es eine Baustelle, und zwar ebenfalls noch bis 5 Uhr früh. Wegen der Baustelle kann immer mal wieder die Fahrbahn gesperrt werden. Also auch hier bitte vorsichtig fahren. Sonst natürlich auch überall und wir wünschen euch eine gute Fahrt.
Danke Jonte, acht Minuten nach halb elf.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Bitte haben Sie noch etwas Geduld. Es wartet noch eine Person vor Ihnen. Bitte haben Sie noch etwas Geduld. Es wartet noch eine Person vor Ihnen.
Ihr hört Chaosradio 189 im Studio Constanze, Nibbler & Kienis. Kann es sein, dass es jetzt um die Telekom geht?
Ja.
Und dass es ein bisschen länger dauert.
Ja, manchmal warten halt noch Leute vor einem.
Ja, wir haben natürlich einen aktuellen Anlass. Mit dem Namen Drosselkomm verbunden. Wir werden gleich noch erzählen, was die Telekom da plant. Aber wir wollen natürlich, wie es sich für eine ordentliche Chaosradio Sendung gehört, auch ein bisschen erklären, worüber da eigentlich der Streit geht und was denn daran so funktional kaputt ist. Und warum sich alle so furchtbar darüber erregen. Vielleicht sollten wir damit mal beginnen, damit wir eine Vorstellung haben, was die Telekom plant. Im Prinzip ist es sehr einfach erklärt. Im Festnetz-DSL-Bereich, da wird die Telekom ab dem Jahr 2016 nach einer jeweils von dem Tarif abhängigen Datenmenge drosseln. Was heißt auf eine geringere Geschwindigkeit herunter dimmen, würde ich es jetzt mal nennen.
Ja, so wie wir es vom Handy kennen halt.
Genau, aber im Festnetz-Bereich ist es natürlich neu. Da gab es so eine Form von Tarifen noch nicht. Man soll es aber auch nicht für die bestehenden Kunden, sondern für die Neukunden.
Auch früher gab es das nicht, als wir alle noch langsam angebunden waren.
Darüber kann man sich streiten. Man fing den Internet an.
Ich kann mich daran erinnern, es gab früher Zeitbeschränkungen. Ich durfte zum Beispiel damals, als ich am DFN, glaube ich, über einen Clients Provider, an der Uni, über einen Clients Provider, der da irgendwie dran kam, ich durfte nur zwischen 16 Uhr und 8 Uhr morgens ins Internet. Ansonsten hat der Provider bei mir angerufen und gesagt, Sie wissen doch, das ist dann aber so ein Business Zugang und das kostet dann richtig Geld. Weil unsere Geschäftskunden so, aber dass die Tempo gedrosselt hätten, habe ich nicht erlebt. Wobei damals konntest du auch nichts drosseln, so langsamer ging ja nicht.
Naja, also die Ideen, dass man Tarife anders gestaltet, die sind natürlich auch in anderen Ländern zu beobachten und gab es auch schon früher. Aber wir sind natürlich jetzt seit über einer Dekade gewisse Ysaussen gewöhnt als Kunden. Und nicht nur als wir als Endkunden, sondern natürlich auch.
Dass man halt, wenn man eine Flatrate kauft, die dann auch bekommt und nicht ein verkapptes Volumenpaket bekommt. Also das letzte Mal, als ich das gesehen habe, das war vor ein paar Jahren in Südafrika, wo das Problem bestand, dass einfach der internationale Datenverkehr so teuer war. Da hat man in seinem Internetpaket irgendwie 5-15 Gigabyte internationale Bandbreite bekommen. Und alles, was in Land war, war völlig wurscht. Aber internationale Bandbreite gab es dann halt nur 15 Gigabyte.
Das wäre argumentativ zumindest nachvollziehbar.
Da wollen wir eigentlich mal drüber reden, wie sind denn eigentlich die Argumente? Ich glaube, ein zentrales ist dieser sogenannte Engpass oder Kapazitätsengpässe, aus denen sich das ja begründet, die auch glaube ich erstmal viele relativ einsichtig finden, wenn man die nicht hinterfragt.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das finde ich ja nicht mal ich einsichtig.
Ich glaube, das zieht schon bei vielen Leuten, die jetzt so ein bisschen in die normalen Zeitungen lesen und vielleicht nicht die Techpresse, so sagen ja, ist ja immer voll, wenn mein YouTube-Video ruckelt, da muss es ja wohl einen Engpass geben. Das ist ja so ein bisschen die Denke. Und da wollen wir noch mal ein bisschen drüber reden, denn wir haben ja eigentlich mehrere Schichten im Netz sozusagen, wo solche Engpässe entstehen können. Und die meisten denken natürlich immer an ihren eigenen Endnutzeranschluss, aber wir wollen auch ein bisschen über das Backbone reden, also über die Strukturen, die eigentlich das Netz bilden.
Die Bandbreitenpakete sind ja auch so berechnet, dass das durchaus für den durchschnittlichen und unterdurchschnittlichen Nutzer meinetwegen ausreichen mag, aber wenn man dann eine Familie hat, wo dann irgendwie sich mehrere Leute das Paket teilen dürfen, dann ist zur Mitte des Monats das Geschrei groß, ob der Sohn mal wieder zu viel YouTube geguckt hat und man jetzt nur noch Telekom Entertainment-Fernsehen gucken darf, weil alles ansonsten langsam ist.
Genau, also ich glaube, der Streit wird erst noch richtig kommen. Im Mobilfunkbereich sind wir ja einigend gewöhnt. Wir wollen nachher auch mal ein bisschen die Unterschiede darstellen. Aber wir wollen natürlich auch über Diskriminierung reden. Dann ist ja gerade auch der Streit, inwieweit und was wird hier eigentlich diskriminiert und weswegen lohnt es sich, dagegen zu kämpfen. Wenn man über Diskriminierung... Na, Linus, sag ruhig.
beende ruhig deinen Satz.
Er macht nur so Zeichen hier so geheim bei jemandem. Also es gibt halt verschiedene Formen der Diskriminierung und die sollte man sich schon mal überlegen. Es sind im Netz eigentlich sechs Formen der Diskriminierung, die es geben können. Manche sind unmittelbar einsichtig. Also man kann bestimmte Inhalte diskriminieren. Man kann natürlich auch die Datenmenge diskriminieren. Kann man sich überlegen. Dann kann man je nachdem, was man bezahlt hat, bestimmte Qualitäts-Services diskriminieren. Man kann aber auch einzelne Nutzer eventuell diskriminieren, was ist möglich, oder auch einzelne Dienstanbieter. Und als letztes kann man natürlich auch bestimmte Programme oder Services diskriminieren. Und das wollen wir noch mal besprechen, was hier eigentlich der Fall ist. Und warum man sich lohnt, dafür zu kämpfen, dass dieser Weg vielleicht noch nicht bestritten wird.
Genau, da kommen wir dann zu der gesellschaftlichen Bedeutung. Mir fiel das gerade sein, als du gesagt hast, seit wann ist irgendwie Internet und so? Für viele von uns fing das vielleicht noch mit dem Dial-up-Modem an oder so. Da haben wir ja total beschissene Tarife gehabt. Ich hab da pro Minute bezahlen müssen. Das war überhaupt nicht an Bandbreite gekoppelt. Aber irgendwann kam dann dieses DSL für... Und es spielt da einfach keine Rolle?
Die erste Flatrate Tomorrow 1999. So ein CD für 77 Mark im Monat sollte das kosten.
Das war noch Dial-up, oder?
Nee, das war ISDN.
Aber dann kam dieses DSL und du warst einfach immer online, das war völlig egal.
Außer wenn du da gewohnt hast, wo ich gewohnt habe, als das DSL kam.
Aber da fing dieses Konzept an, überhaupt mal der wirklich der vernetzten Gesellschaft, das hatte da eigentlich seine Geburtsstunde.
Dass im Internet sowas ist wie Wasser aus dem Hahn oder Strom aus der Steckdose, das ist halt einfach da und also fände das jetzt auch befremdlich, wenn irgendwie mir mein Stromanbieter mitteilt. Ja, also backen, das machen sie vielleicht zweimal im Monat, aber wie häufiger als zweimal im Monat backt, da kaufen sie sich dann das Backpaket plus, dann können sie da noch mal einen KW irgendwie um ihren Kuchen, weil das ist Power Usage.
Also es ist natürlich so, dass es glaube ich für alle Leute klar ist, dass sich einiges geändert hat. Ich glaube, die multimedialen Inhalte, die so seit 5, 6 Jahren immer stärker verbreitet werden, haben natürlich auf die Bandbreite einen gewissen Einfluss. Es ist halt heute nicht mehr nur Text und Bild, sondern es ist natürlich Bewegbild und in großen Mengen und die Streaming Services und dergleichen. Also da hat sich eine Menge getan.
Das war ja auch nicht vorhersehbar. Da konnte man ja nicht mit rechnen, wenn man so ein Netz aufbaut und alle 60 Kilobit sind genug für jeden.
Ja genau. Also klar, wenn man jetzt wieder als Endnutzer guckt, dann merkt man natürlich ja, der Druck wird manchmal, wo man gerade ist. Aber wenn man in den Backbone-Bereich mal hineinschaut, dann wird man sehr schnell wissen, dass es wirklich Kapazitätsengpässe wirklich gibt.
Kann man das tatsächlich berechnen?
Es ist behebbar. Eine Netzplanung funktioniert grundsätzlich so, dass man halt sein Netz einen Überblick hat. Guckt, wo gibt es Engpässe, wo kann man was dagegen tun? Und wenn man jetzt feststellt, zwischen meinem Netz und dem Netz von Google für YouTube, die Leute klicken schon wieder an mehr Katzenvideos als letzten Monat, dann steckt man da einfach noch mal ein Interface in seinen Router und teilt sich die Kosten für eine Faser, was nicht die Welt ist. Lass es im oberen zweistelligen, im unteren dreistelligen Euro-Bereich im Monat sein, für so eine Faser innerhalb so eines Rechenzentrums, um sich mit einem weiteren Port an so ein Netz anzubinden, wo dann wieder 10 Gigabit oder 100 Gigabit drüber gehen. Da muss die Bereitschaft auf beiden Seiten zu da sein. Das nennt man Peering, in dem Fall ein privates Peering, dass ein Netzbetreiber zu einem anderen Netzbetreiber eine Faser dazwischen packen und dann ihre Daten austauschen. Dass die Katzenbilder zum Internetzugangsprovider kommen oder umgekehrt. Da stellen sich Art Helikos wie die Deutsche Telekom auf den Punkt. Wir sind das Internet, ihr könnt gerne Internet von uns kaufen, wenn ihr unsere Kunden haben wollt oder wenn ihr wollt, dass euer YouTube oder eure Internetseite eurer Kunden, wenn das nicht ruckeln soll und wenn unsere Kunden auf eure Dienste zugreifen können sollen, dann zahlt bitte dafür. Ihr könnt gerne Internet von uns kaufen, ob ihr dann über uns Internet bezieht oder nur zu unseren eigenen Kunden kommt, ist uns egal. Der Standardweg, um mit der Telekom Daten auszutauschen, ist tatsächlich nicht ein freies Peering, sondern ist von der Telekom, sich einen Internetzugang zu kaufen, und zwar auch für Größere. Und selbst im Fall von Google kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass die Telekom, also kann ich aus berechtigtem Grund nicht vorstellen, dass die Telekom das gerne kostenlos macht, sondern dass sie da sehr wohl Geld für haben wollen.
Interessant ist nicht so, dass die Anbieter unter sich alle im Austausch machen, sondern das hat teilweise, je nachdem, wie groß und marktmächtig einer ist.
Es verhält sich der Monopolist, wie ein Monopolist in alle Richtungen. Was ich nicht ganz begreife ist, dass das mit dem Kapazitätsengpass offensichtlich die Unwahrheit ist.
Naja, ich hab jetzt mal über das Backbone-Netz gesprochen. Da haben wir es sogar schriftlich.
Dass es nicht die, dass es die Unwahrheit ist?
Der Bundestag wollte von den deutschen großen Providern mal wissen, leg uns mal ein paar Zahlen auf den Tisch. Und ich war ja Mitglied in der Enquete-Kommission und da haben wir diese Zahlen auch bekommen. Und da haben wir schriftlich bestätigt bekommen, dass wir dort diesen Backbone-Bereich derzeit bei den deutschen Netzbetreibern keine Kapazität sein können.
Okay, aber das ist noch, das heißt, die Telekom hat noch nicht gelogen. Weil sie könnten auch noch eine andere Kapazität meinen.
Ja, sie könnten, also es gibt ja sozusagen auch das Backhole-Netz, da sieht es vielleicht ein bisschen anders aus. Vor allen Dingen wurde aber natürlich auch viel geredet über letzte Meile, klar. Also das sind natürlich sehr verschiedene Ebenen, die, wenn man darüber argumentiert, dann sehr oft vermischt werden. Ich will aber gerne noch...
Also wir waren glaube ich gerade einfach, um das nochmal zu verdeutlichen, wir waren jetzt gerade auf der Ebene des Datencenters oder des Internet-Exchanges und der Aufsehkabel.
Zwischen größere Netze und auf der innersten Netzebene in so einem, also wo man jetzt ein paar Locations in einem Land hat, die miteinander sehr gut vernetzt sind und etliche Netzübergänge und andere Netze. Das andere Ende von so einem Provider-Netz ist das zum Nutzer hingewandte, also der Teil des Netzes, der dann in letzter Konsequenz man im Kasten auf der Straße stehen sieht. Und da gibt es dann natürlich schon das Problem, dass da die 10 Gigabit Interfaces immer noch Geld kosten und der Ausbau dort entsprechend schon preisintensiv ist. Wenn man ein bisschen mehr als das eine MBit, was unsere Kanzlerin glaub ich mal als wir brauchen Breitband in ganz Deutschland, mindestens ein MBit für alle, wenn man ein bisschen mehr möchte als das minimale Zugeständnis an dieses Jahrtausend, dann wird das schon schwierig.
Aber dazu muss ich ja nicht so ein komisches Preismodell fahren, sondern das kann ich ja die Kunden auch unmittelbar bezahlen lassen.
Nee, aber das Preismodell ermöglicht dir, den Ausbau aufzuschieben, weil dann werden die Kunden dazu angehalten, nicht so viel zu nutzen. Was total widersinnig ist, weil dann hast du trotzdem die Bandbreite auf deinem Netz nur halt für einen halben Monat.
Ja, das habe ich dann an dieser Diskussion auch nicht wirklich verstanden. Es wird dann halt gedrosselt, aber es gibt mindestens einen Tag im Monat, muss es doch eigentlich geben, wo alle gleichzeitig mit voller Geschwindigkeit da rumsaugen irgendwas.
Soll ich mal spoilern, Holgi? Das geht hier nicht um Ausbau. Das geht um Geld machen. Aber dazu kommen wir erst später.
Wenn man sich das überlegt, man muss sich immer ein bisschen die Zahlen und Fakten beim Netz überlegen. Die Stoßzeiten, wo du zu den Peaks kommst, sind ja in Deutschland überraschenderweise nicht tagsüber zu Geschäftszeiten, sondern die sind zwischen 20 und 23 Uhr. Da kann man sehr deutlich die Peaks sehen. Ich hab mal nachgeguckt. Wir haben beim größten Internetknoten in Deutschland, dem Dezix, da haben wir da so 1, 2 Terabyte pro Sekunde. Nun kann man sich mal fragen, wie weit sind die denn aufgerüstet? Also was könnten die denn durchleiten? Und da sind wir schon bei über 40 Terabyte. Das heißt natürlich, dass die Backbone, generell die Anbieter dort, die verschiedenen, die haben natürlich längst den Wachstum des Traffics, des Datenverkehrs schon antizipiert. Die haben ihre Technik darauf auch eingestellt. Denn man fängt nicht erst an, wenn man merkt, oh ich bin oberkant der Unterlippe auszubauen. Weil anders ist es natürlich zu Hause sozusagen bei den letzten Meilen. Aber deswegen ist es, wenn man darüber nachdenkt, nicht unbedingt so, dass man eigentlich so ein Tarifmodell wie jetzt vorgeschlagen nehmen müsste. Man müsste eigentlich sagen, hey wir drosseln. Um eine bestimmte Uhrzeit stattdessen.
Stimmt, das wäre richtig.
Ja, stimmt.
Leuchtet ein.
Großbritannien ist doch der Fall. Die haben doch genau das gemacht. Die haben gesagt, oh wir haben ja zwischen 20 und 23 Uhr einen Peak. Wo kommt denn der her? Ach so, die Leute nutzen alle das Angebot des BBC iPlayers. Da müssen wir mal was gegen machen. Wir machen das jetzt einfach so, dass das für alle nicht funktioniert in der Uhrzeit. Und das kostet drei Pfund extra, wenn ihr möchtet, dass das funktioniert.
Das ist wenigstens ehrlich.
Das ist einerseits ehrlich.
Das ist diskriminierend natürlich, aber es ist ehrlich.
Das ist diskriminierend. Natürlich kommste dir als Netzanbieter ein bisschen gelackmeiert vor, wenn du eine Glasfaser nach der anderen reinsteckst, um deine Kunden glücklich zu halten, die dir jeden Monat das gleiche Geld überweisen und derjenige, der dir die ganzen Bits da reinbläst, der fährt irgendwie Ferrari. Da hast du irgendwann keine Lust. Dann ist natürlich naheliegend zu sagen, was können wir denn da machen, wenn wir da auch was von haben möchten, von diesem Geld. Und dann kann man ja mal hingehen und sagen, schönen Videodienst haben sie da.
Das wäre doch schade, wenn ihm was passiert.
Genau das ist passiert. Das war British Telekom, glaube ich, die das damals bei dem iPlayer gemacht haben. Das haben die immer noch. British Telekom, die waren das. Das haben die meines Wissens immer noch aktiv. Diesen Tarif buchen sie den iPlayer. Selektiv den attraktivsten Dienst des Internets für genau die attraktive Zeit rausgenommen. Da wollen wir ein paar Mark mehr haben, ein paar Pfund mehr haben.
Am Ende des Tages hast du dann halt keinen Internetzugang mehr, sondern dann hast du irgendwie halt...
Oder einen Dienstezugang, oder einen Anbieterzugang.
Und genau darum dreht sich auch so ein bisschen der Streit hier, denn die Debatte ging ja auch darum, darf man das einen Bruch der Netzeutralität nennen? Und wie wäre die denn überhaupt definiert? Oder ist das ja eigentlich eine andere Form von Diskriminierung, die man aus anderen Gründen bekämpfen könnte? Also der Streit ist ja auch sofort in Brand. Kaum, dass das öffentlich wurde. Gerüchte gab es ja schon eine ganze Weile, aber nun war ja vor ein paar Tagen die Pressemitteilung dazu. Und auch mit den konkreten Tarifmodellen. Und ab wann beginnt eben 2016? Und darüber kann man sich natürlich schon streiten. Denn diese T-Entertain, wovon hier die Rede ist, die hat eigentlich mit dem normalen Netzzugang nichts zu tun, sondern ist ein unterschiedlicher Dienst.
Ist zwar auch IP-basiert, aber ist halt nicht Internet, sondern das ist nochmal ein paralleles Angebot zum Internet dazu.
Was benutzt du dieselben Leitungen?
Ja, aber dein Telefon ist ja auch da drauf. Also du hast ja viele Sachen auf dem Kupfer. Jetzt würde mich nur mal interessieren, an welcher Stelle kommt das Entertain? Also wo steht Entertain und wo steht Internet?
Ich weiß nicht, was Ninos fragen will. Kannst du die Frage nochmal um?
Du meinst physikalisch? Worauf wir physikalisch eigentlich ansprechen ist, es gibt ein DSL-Netz, das gehört der Deutschen Telekom und der aber bieten sie ihren Kunden auch Internet an. Und auch T-Entertain. Und deswegen ist die, glaube ich, technisch korrekte Interpretation, wenn sie dir das gesamte Internet abdrehen und Entertain weiter liefern, verletzen sie damit nicht die Netzneutralität, weil sie dir alle Dienste des Internets, die du nutzen möchtest, komplett runterfahren. Aber Entertain ist eben kein Dienst des Internets.
So könnte man argumentieren.
Man kann sich in nächster Konsequenz streiten, ob Spotify zum Beispiel ein Internetdienst ist oder ob das ein Dienst der Deutschen Telekom ist. Denn das haben wir im Mobilfunk jetzt schon, dass die Telekom sagt, ok, Internet ist zwar im Paket, aber wir verkaufen dir für einen zusätzlichen Obolus diesen Internetdienst Spotify in Unlimitiert dazu. Und da geht die Reise halt tatsächlich hin und das ist hoch bedenklich, weil die Zugangsanbieter sich dann sozusagen zum Zöllner vor dem Kunden mausern und sagen, ok, wenn du an unsere Kunden möchtest, dann wollen wir da gerne mitverdienen dran.
Da gehen uns dann aber ganz schnell die Argumente aus, wenn wir das nicht mehr über Netzneutralität und das ist halt eine moralische Frage.
Spotify steht ja woanders. Da ist ja relativ klar, die Spotify-Server stehen im Internet und Spotify kommt auch übers Internet zu mir.
Man kann es ja auch außerhalb der Telekom buchen, kann man ja machen.
Kann man auch außerhalb der Telekom buchen, aber dann zahlst du, wenn du über deine 3G-Verbindung Spotify hörst, zahlst du jedes Byte davon. Für Spotify ist dieser Deal super interessant. Wunderbar, die Telekom vermarktet uns. Take this Konkurrenz. Und für jeden, der Spotify Konkurrenz machen möchte, ist das natürlich ein sehr großes Problem, überhaupt einen Markteintritt zu schaffen.
Müsst ihr nicht die FDP hier total aufschreien?
Die FDP müsste hier aufschreien. Ich meine, liebe FDP, lasst euch das nicht bieten.
Ach, hat die Geduld schon erwähnt? Wir sind doch hier, genau, wir sind gerettet.
Wir sind gerettet?
Herr Rösler hat auch gesagt, er ist da nicht so dafür.
Er hat einen Brief geschrieben.
Und Ilse Aigner?
Unter Protest hat sie ihren Facebook-Account.
Die braucht das Internet zwar nicht mehr, aber den Facebook-Account hat sie. Sie hat einfach ihren Mobilfunkvertrag jetzt nicht mehr verlängert, weil ihr nicht einfiel, dass Festnetz und Mobilfunk nicht das gleiche sind.
Ja, ich meine, wir haben uns halt für Ilse Aigner statt für Verbraucherschutz entschieden. Ist schon in Ordnung.
Wir sollten übrigens mal ein bisschen inklusiv werden, oder? Wenn wir wollen, dass Leute sich äußern können, wir haben jetzt schon ein bisschen den Streit, dann sollten wir mal die Nummer ansagen.
Stimmt, das ist nämlich eine Hörertalk-Sendung hier, auch wenn das manchmal nicht den Eindruck macht. 0331 70 97 110 ist unsere Nummer und weil auch immer was Qualifiziertes beizutragen hat oder eine Frage zu stellen hat, ruft uns hier gehört. Genau, ruf mich an, Katschi.
Ihr kriegt aber keine Wartemusik. Weil sich einige MVC gefragt haben, ob wir uns hier hören.
Und ihr dürft euch auch nichts wünschen, außer Weltfrieden. Lass mich mal hier. 0331 70 97 167. Chaos Radio 189 ist hier. Es geht um die Telekom und da ist was kaputt.
und zwar in seiner wichtigsten Funktionalität, auf unter 1% eingeschränkt. Dann ist es einfach funktional kaputt.
Ich hab da immer Mario Bart vor meinem geistigen Auge, wenn ich das höre. Und der sagt, kennt ihr das? Ist funktional kaputt. Kennt ihr das? Internet? Kennt ihr das? Kennt ihr das? Ist kaputt. Funktional.
Frau war wieder shoppen. Den ganzen Volumen aufgebraucht.
Ein schönes Lied gibt es bei iTunes für eine Mark. Und die Einnahmen davon kommen einem guten Zweck zugute. Kommen einem sinnvollen Zweck zugute. Sehr schön. Werden nämlich durchgereicht an die digitale Gesellschaft.
Genau, da läuft auch eine Kampagne und auch nicht erst seit heute. Die ist aus meiner Sicht auch ganz, war teilweise ziemlich humoristisch geraten. Also es geht auch nicht.
Das sind diese Werbeplakate, die überall durchs Netz fliegen.
Ja, die sind ziemlich lustig. Es geht auch nicht nur um die Telekom. Also wir haben natürlich vergleichbare Probleme, die uns da drohen, auch von anderen Anbietern.
Na das werden alle so machen.
Na und im Mobilfunkbereich haben wir den heute schon, ja.
Wobei Mobilfunk schon noch mal was anderes ist.
Ist anders natürlich und wir haben auch einen anderen Markt da, das sollte man nicht vergessen. Also wir reden...
Das wird ja auch immer begründet mit tatsächlich dem Markt, dass das ja ein Markt ist und dass man auf einen Markt den Einzelnen nicht vorschreiben kann, was sie anzubieten haben. Und das Problem ist, dass das für den Mobilfunk durchaus zutreffen mag. Da hat die Bundesnetzagentur auch dafür gesorgt, dass jeder ungefähr gleichgroße Stück am Frequenzkuchen hat, seine Basisituation aufbauen kann. Und so im Groben und Ganzen die Bedingungen für alle vier Netzbetreiber, das ist T-Mobile, das ist Vodafone, das ist Telefonica O2, das ist E-Flux und deren Resellerinfrastruktur, dass die sich das aufteilen können, dass da jeder gleiche Chancen hat. Das sieht im Festnetz komplett anders aus. Da gibt es eben die über mehrere Jahrzehnte vom Steuerzahler noch in Staatshand in den Boden gebuddelten Kupferkabel, die dort liegen sozusagen die letzte Meile zum Kunden hin. Also das, was von dem Telekom-Scheidkasten auf der Straße zu euch in den Anschlussplatz im Keller und zu Hause ins heimliche Wohnzimmer geht. Diese letzte Meile, das ist sozusagen größtenteils über 99 Prozent alles Telekom.
Also bis heute, obwohl der Markt liberalisiert werden sollte.
Da gibt es natürlich für alle Anbieter, die das haben wollen, die Möglichkeit sich das zu kaufen. Das nennt sich dann Teilnehmeranschlussleitung. Die mieten dann sozusagen für ein Zehner von der Telekom den Kupfer zwischen der Telefonlose bei dir zu Hause bis zum Verteiler. Und können dann da ihr eigenes Equipment dranhängen. Können sich also in die Telekom-Vermittlungsstellen ihre eigene Hardware reinstellen und dann dort der Telekom-Konkurrenz machen.
Ich könnte also, wenn jetzt alle hingehen und sagen, wir drosseln jetzt alles, könnte ich eine eigene Firma gründen, die sagt, ich lief euch jetzt Internet nach Hause, ich drossel nicht, würde das sauber kalkulieren und dann würde das meinetwegen 50er-Kosten oder so, aber dafür hättest du dann wirklich...
Dann kannst du sozusagen der Telekom-Konkurrenz machen, indem du ihr diese Leitung abmietest und indem du der Telekom Geld für Hardware zur Telekom stellen gibst, dann kannst du dann der Telekom Konkurrenz machen.
Und stell dir vor, das ist natürlich auch die Hoffnung der Marktliberalen, denn der Markt wird's ja richten. Nicht wahr? Da steht ja auch so ein Koalitionsvertrag.
Der Markt wird's richten?
Ja, naja, ein bisschen. Also, das ist ja eklig formuliert.
Wir einigen uns auf, der Markt wird's richten.
Ich glaube, jetzt hat das Motto, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, oder?
Der Markt wird's richten.
Marktkonforme Demokratie.
Marktkonforme Demokratie. Marktgerecht, glaube ich. Marktgerecht. Das hat Merkel mal gesagt.
Nee, aber der Witz ist halt, dass die da quasi Monopol haben und ja, also um ihnen da Konkurrenz zu machen, muss man sich ihre Infrastruktur bedienen.
Aber die Art und Weise und die Kosten, die man da hat, um sich der Infrastruktur zu bedienen, die sind wiederum gesetzlich geregelt.
Die sind von der Bundesnetzagentur tatsächlich reguliert. Die reguliert zum einen sowas, die reguliert auch die Kosten, die Netzbetreiber untereinander bei Sprache haben. Also die sagen zum Beispiel, wie viel eine Minute Telefonie in Mobilfunknetzkosten darf bei der Netzübergabe und so zeugs.
Oder auch die Rufnummern, also all die Fragen, um die sich die Kunden auch immer streiten. Wir hatten in der Unkeitkommission den Präsidenten der Bundesnetzagentur, der heißt Matthias Kurth, auch mal zu Besuch und konnten an den einige Fragen richten. Auch in Bezug auf die Regulierung, wie er sich das in Zukunft vorstellt, aber auch in Bezug auf die Kapazitätsgrenzen, die es da gibt, also die Engpässe. Und tatsächlich ist es so, dass die Bundesnetzagentur im Bereich der Mobilfunksituation eigentlich gar nichts reguliert, weil sie einfach sagt, na da ist ein Markt, wir erheben da auch keine Zahlen. Sie wissen also auch gar nicht, wann sind denn eigentlich Engpässe, wie sehen die aus. Und überhaupt nur im Festnetzbereich tätig werden und da eigentlich auch nur nachwirkend. Also häufig ist es so, dass sie reagieren auf Beschwerden, also wenn sich Leute beschwerden, aber nicht unbedingt präventiv tätig werden. Das war so ein bisschen die Message, die er uns da gab. Na ja, kann man sich natürlich auch mal ansehen, wie die Bundesnetzagentur zusammengesetzt ist. Und wer das sagen hat, wundert man sich dann auch nicht mehr.
Lass mal ein bisschen telefonieren, oder? 0331 77 91 10 der Thomas hat anrufen, oder Thomas?
Fio, ich wollte hinzufügen, dass wir ja das Internet auch zur politischen Beteiligung nutzen wollen und können, zum Beispiel Bundestagsreden hören und das Beispiel jetzt hier vom Herrn Ull zu dieser OZAP-Stift, die Differenz zwischen der Rede und dem Papier, die war ja sehr erheiterndlich, fand.
Du spielst jetzt an auf die Rede, die erhielt nach dem Aufdeckung der Staatstrojaner, wo dann man fanden Protokollen, schriftliche davon und das schriftliche Protokoll hat wich ab von der gesprochenen Rede, die aber gestreamt wurde, die konnte man sich ansehen. Die erklärt jetzt nur, wenn die Leute dich...
Aber das ist ja oft, dass das abweicht. Das ist aber ganz interessant, wie viel Bandbreite braucht eigentlich DE-Mail?
Also derzeit sehr wenig, benutzt ja kaum jemand.
Kann man mit 384 Kilo wird wahrscheinlich nur nutzen.
Ja, würde ich auch sagen.
Das heißt, das Argument fällt auch aus. Ich dachte, ich hätte jetzt irgendwie eine tolle Interaktion gefunden.
Wollte irgendjemand in einer Türkei ins Internet Video auch möglicherweise multimediale Inhalte per DE-Mail versenden?
Das Problem ist aber tatsächlich schon, wenn in einer Familie, die alle sich ein 100 Gigabyte Paket teilen müssen und die kleine Schwester mit YouTube am Anfang des Monats verwallert und am Ende des Monats die große nicht die Telelearning-Video-Tutorials von ihrer Uni gucken kann, dann ist das einfach ein soziales Problem, was du darauf weißt.
Die Perspektive, so eine Welt, wie die FDP sie gerne hätte, wer am meisten zahlen kann, kriegt die besten Dienste.
Also was die Telekom möchte, sie drosseln ja nicht auf ein Niveau, wo das noch gehen würde. Sie drosseln ja auf eine Schwierigkeit.
5 Megabit oder 10 Megabit oder was auch immer, oder 10% deines Anschlusses oder 5%, ne das ist unter 1%.
So, sie drosseln auf ein Niveau, wo es wirklich schmerzt und wo du es nicht mehr nutzen kannst.
Und wo man die Telekom-Seite mit den Bildern nicht mehr richtig aufrufen kann.
Aber das ist ja ehrheulig, das ist kein Problem.
Garantiert, weil wenn du die Telekom-Seite aufrufst mit deinem Telekom-Anschluss, dann geht das noch schnell.
Wie war das? Eine Minute sonst was mit 348 Kilobit die Telekom-Seite?
Ja, aber wenn du in deren Netz unterwegs bist, dann werden sie es garantiert nochmal. Ah, der hat unsere Seite gepinkt, wir regeln mal kurz hoch. Und zack, wieder aus.
Vielleicht werden wir damit auch diese blöden, die ganzen Banner weg. Kriegen wir die weg? Also die anderen Menschen und ihren Bauern.
Also die Bandbreite kenn ich nicht mehr, nur aus Hotels, wo das bewusst so limitiert wird, dass gerade noch so YouPorn nicht mehr geht, damit die Leute die Fernsehkanäle mit dem Pay-TV-Programm im Hotel gucken und nicht das aus dem Internet ziehen. Das sind diese 384 Kilobit, das ist genau so der...
Darf ich nicht mal von so einem Hörer zurückkommen, der eine interessante Anmerkung machte? Thomas, bist du noch da? Genau. Ah, gut, wir wollten dich nicht so abwirken, die Männern sind heute schwer zu stoppen.
Und über das Internet bin ich halt auch auf euch gestoßen, also ich aufs Chaosradio und die Bildung finde ich auch eigentlich sehr gut. Ich wohne in Isachsen, ich empfange das nicht über UKW, sondern übers Internet und das würde man mir halt verwehren, auch die Podcasts, die jetzt das öffentlich-rechtliche Internet stellt und man könnte jetzt argumentieren, dass der Staat dann dafür zahlen muss, aber mir wird auch nicht der Fernsehanschluss bei Hartz IV verwehrt, warum soll es mir dann auch verwehrt werden, das übers Internet zu machen.
Es wird dir ja nicht verwehrt, es wird dir ja nur erschwert.
Du musst ein bisschen haushalten, die Idee, also die Vision ist ja hier nicht, dass du kein Internet mehr hast, die Vision ist, dass du relativ einfach nachzahlst, darum geht's, es geht dir nicht darum, das Land irgendwie ohne Internet dastehen zu lassen, das möchten sie nicht, sie möchten einfach, dass die Leute...
Das ist halt eine verkappte Einführung von Volumentarifen, indem man die Flatrate so beschneidet, dass es keine Flatrate mehr ist, sondern das Ganze effektiv in einen Volumentarif umstellt und du halt für deine Grundgebühren Inklusivvolumen bekommst und das Inklusivvolumen jederzeit um weiteres Volumenpaket erweitern kannst. Das klappt immer so, ich finde. Das klappt schon hervorragend. Wenn du beispielsweise bei Vodafone, glaube ich, so dein Volumen aufgebraucht hast, dann kriegst du ja SMS reingeboten, hey, möchtest du nicht noch mal weitere und weitere?
Und wenn nicht, kriegst du 32 Kilobit im Mobilfunknetz, das ist überhaupt nichts, das ist weniger als ein 56k Modem.
Echt, bei Vodafone oder was?
Ja, bei O2 auch, bei bestimmten Tarifen, also draußen sind sie nicht auf 32 Kilobit.
Bei mir ist das auch, beim Handy, also ich hab mal eins von der Telekom, das kannst du nachkaufen. 64 Kilobit, geh mal hin. Na gut Thomas, ich glaub Thomas freut schon.
Das ist ja nichts, worüber du mich freuen solltest.
Das ist eine Sache, das ist doch, ich verdiene genug im Moment, weißt du, das ist halt...
Du freust dich darüber, dass du dein Geld ausgeben darfst.
Ich freu mich darüber, dass ich es mir überhaupt leisten könnte.
Ja, worauf Thomas hinausfährt, ist glaube ich dieser Grundversorgungsgedanke und die Idee, dass man unter einer bestimmten Bandbreite irgendwas nicht mehr so wirklich als Internet bezeichnen kann oder überhaupt der Bevölkerung so eine Art Grundversorgung zur Verfügung zu stellen hat. Das ist ja auch tatsächlich bei manchen Parteien eine politische Verorderung.
Die Mediatheken guck ich da an.
Na die hat er ja erwähnt, also jetzt, wenn du zum Beispiel Radio hörst, würde man nicht so...
Ja Radio geht ja, ist ja schmalbandig, aber guck dir mal einen Tatort an. Stream mal einen Tatort in dem HD, in dem der Tatort kommt, die anderthalb Stunden sind eineinhalb Gigabyte.
Thomas, was würdest du denn sagen, wenn die Telekom dir jetzt sagt, ja, ARD-Mediathek sehen wir ein, das hast du ja auch über deine Gebühren bezahlt, die ARD-Mediathek schließen wir davon aus, die kriegst du.
Nein, weil ich höre ja auch Podcasts, ich bin von den bösen iTunes Nutzer, die da so von sich Podcasts abonnieren und auch regelmäßig auch... Verschiedenste, also Deutschlandfunk, ich bin morgens in der Universität, da kann ich den nicht hören, also höre ich es nachmittags. Und das glät es halt runter, dann kann ich das nachmittags hören.
Und du hast ja so ein Paket, wo Bildungsinhalte und Öffentlich-Rechtliche dabei sind. Also die wäre für dich als Telekom-Kunde interessant?
Interessant schon, man muss es sich leisten können. Und dieses Video, was jetzt online steht mit meine Eltern haben kein Geld dafür, das finde ich dort ein Anstoßen.
Okay, also du hast da eine klare Haltung.
Genau.
Das ist schon mal eine deutliche Meinung.
Was zu der partizipativen Geschichte auch noch dazukommt, die meisten Kunden, eigentlich alle Kunden, die in VDSL, die in ADSL zu Hause haben, nutzen ja auch nur so die Hälfte ihres Anschlusses, weil du kriegst 250 MBit down, theoretisch bekämpfst du auch 25 MBit ab. Das ist in der VDSL jetzt pro spekso drin. Wenn man irgendwie nachguckt, bei bestimmten, bei bestimmten Daten, wer geht das, sieht man wie viel Bandbreite denn da zur Verfügung stünde. So und der das 25 MBit im Upstream und nicht nur 10, das heißt die Telekom nutzt die Hälfte ihres Netzes eh nicht. Weil die Kunden tatsächlich ja nur den Downstream haben. Also das ist eh schon so ein bisschen BTX und Steroids mit irgendwie, früher hatte man da 1200 baud down und 25 ab oder so. Ja, also das ist eh schon in einer Art und Weise beschnitten, dass es wirklich auf den Konsum zugeschnitten ist und nicht als Zugang für mündige Netzbürger, die selbst auch Inhalte produzieren.
Also dennoch, also die Netzhinterne Tätdebatte, die wir da so haben, die muss man glaube ich trotzdem ein bisschen kritisch betrachten, weil eine andere Form von Diskriminierung ist oder auch eine andere Form von Regulierung dieses Marktes. Wir haben ein Fakt, dass die Telekom nicht mehr nur Netzanbieter ist, sondern natürlich auch längst Content-Anbieter, Herteanbieter. Und diese Vermischung, die macht sich in dieser Neukalkulation der Tarife ganz klar deutlich.
Weil es eben plötzlich interessant wird, den Kunden bestehende Produkte einzuschränken. Also einen Schritt zurückzunehmen und zu behaupten, ja wir haben da Engpässe, wir haben gerade festgestellt, dass wir eigentlich mit dem Wasser haben, mehr Geld verdienen können, Engpässe haben. Ja und dann eben unter dem Stichwort Engpässe Dinge zu Geld machen, bei denen sie vorher kein Problem hatten, einem das so zu geben. Also das ist eine eiskalte Monetarisierung von Staatseigentum.
Ist ja nicht so, dass wir das nicht alle bezahlt hätten.
Darum fand ich es so charmant, die Spontanreaktion von Christopher Lauer, enteignet den Scheißladen, fand ich irgendwie ganz charmant.
Aber ist doch im Prinzip so, dass wir den eigentlich schon haben.
Das heißt Deprivatisierung.
Deprivatisierung und das würde ja reichen, die Infrastruktur zu deprivatisieren, den Rest können sie ja behalten. Die Hotlines.
Na ja, wir sollten vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang auch nochmal ganz kurz über Best Effort reden. Also wenn man über das Prinzip der Paketvermittlung redet im Netz, dann sind ja meistens die Best Effort Netzer. Das bedeutet einfach, dass man sich größtmöglich Mühe gibt, fair durchzuleiten. Und die Frage wird halt sein, ob man in Zukunft tatsächlich von diesem Best Effort Prinzip abgewichen wird. Dass man sich also unabhängig vom Inhalt und unabhängig von demjenigen, der es einstellt oder auch unabhängig vom Protokoll Mühe gibt, es bestmöglich durchzuleiten. Das ist ja eigentlich die Frage, die hinter der Netzetreite steht und die ja auch in den Debatten, die darüber früher schon geführt wurden, immer wieder im Mittelpunkt stand. Wir sind ja in Deutschland nicht die ersten. Die Debatte ist ja in den USA schon einige Jahre früher geführt worden, aber auch da geht es eigentlich eher mal so um die Inhalte, zum Beispiel beim Google Verizon Deal, über den damals hier gestritten wurde, wo der amerikanische Gesetzgeber war ein Abkommen zwischen einem großen Telekommunikationsanbieter und Google, über die Frage gestritten wurde, aber nicht wirklich um die Prinzipien des Best Effort. Die sind eigentlich deshalb glaube ich noch nicht Teil der Debatte. Würde ich jedenfalls heute so sehen. Also die eigentlich so den Kern der Netzneutralität ausmachen. Dennoch hast du natürlich ein erster Schritt zu diesem Entertainment Netz, wo man eben ganz klar nach Services und Dienstleistungen unterscheidet.
Du möchtest einfach nicht, dass dein Internetanbieter noch irgendwelche Aktien in dem Bereich hat, was du dir über diesen Internetanschluss anschaust. Das ist eine sehr unheilige Allianz.
Das hat einen klaren Interessenskonflikt, wenn dein Internetprovider ein Interesse daran hat, sich die Inhalte, die du darüber leitung transportierst, genauer anzuschauen.
Da müssen wir natürlich auch nochmal darüber reden. Es ist natürlich erst in den letzten Jahren überhaupt möglich geworden, die Inhalte so klar zu unterscheiden. Und die Technik, die heißt EP, Deep Packet Inspection, dass man also in Echtzeit in die Pakete insofern hineinschauen kann, dass man analysieren kann sofort, auch bei hohem Durchsatz.
Während das Paket sozusagen noch durch das Netz geleitet wird, wird das schon klassifiziert, in eine Traffic-Klasse geschoben. Das Gerät weiß, ist das jetzt Firesharing, ist das irgendwas aus dem und dem Zielnetz. Also du kannst da kategorisieren nach allem, was dir so einfällt. Also das Gerät kann im Prinzip alles. Das ist nur eine Frage, die du programmierst. Also ob du jetzt irgendwie sagst, werf mir bitte mal Firesharing in eine bestimmte Traffic-Klasse, werf mir mal Diensteanbieter, die ihre Netzzolle bezahlt haben in eine spezielle Klasse, werf mir Voice-over-IP in eine Klasse und mach das mal so schlecht, dass man es nicht mehr nutzen kann.
Wie so eine Weiche oder eine mehrstufige Weiche, die man einstellen kann.
Und mit der Klassifizierung kann man eben arbeiten. Da kannst du zum einen dafür sorgen, dass Leute noch Voice-over-IP nutzen können, während sie gerade Filesharing nutzen, was total dufte ist. Du kannst aber auch dafür sorgen, dass das Filesharing nicht funktioniert, dass das Voice-over-IP nicht funktioniert, es sei denn der Nutzer hat das entsprechende Paket dazu gebucht.
Klassischer Fall im Mobilfunkbereich. Also als Mobilfunkanbieter, ich habe kein Interesse daran, ich möchte Minutenpakete an meine Kunden verkaufen, ich habe kein Interesse daran, dass die sagen, ja wunderbar, ich kaufe 5Gb und ansonsten könnt ihr mich mal gerne haben. Ich habe nämlich hier Skype oder Voice-over-IP oder was auch immer. Also sehen sie zu, dass sie sich teure Hardware kaufen, um genau das zu verhindern. Voice-over-IP über 3G, wenn man da nicht noch einen VPN oder so drum schaltet und sich viel Mühe gibt, kriegt man das dann nicht durchgeschoben.
Oder zu sagen, mir ist euer 5Gb Paket relativ groß, ich klicke mir ein 50Mb Paket, weil ich nutze eh nur Instant Messaging. So ich zahle hier keine 10 oder 20 oder 30 Cent pro SMS, sondern nur zahle mein 50Mb Paket für ein paar Euro und mache da mein Instant Messaging drüber.
Was meinst du, was sie sich geärgert haben, als dieses WhatsApp auf einmal ankam? Auf einmal schreiben die alle diese WhatsApp Nachrichten.
Plattformübergreifend. Sonst kannst du mit anderen iPhone-Usern hin und her messagen, aber nicht mit den Android-Usern.
Da sieht man erst mal, wie schlecht das Angebot der Telcos ist, weil WhatsApp ist auch richtig doll schlecht. Also das ist richtig doll mies. Die Übertragener unverschlüsselt dein komplettes Telefonbuch in ihren Dienst rein. What the...
Ja, aber du musst einfach mal, dass wir so einen Facebook-Effekt benutzen.
Das ist klar, aber das demonstriert halt, was für ein Mindestniveau ein Service haben muss, damit die Leute nutzen, nämlich keins. Das Angebot der Telcos ist einfach mal so schlecht, dass sie nicht anders umhinkommen, als andere zu diskriminieren, um ihre eigenen Produkte loszuwerden. Du brauchst da keine große Innovation, um mit ihnen zu konkurrieren. So, und statt die Innovation zu bringen und was zu entwickeln und das Ganze voranzubringen, sagen sie, nee, es ist für uns einfacher da einzugreifen und das Geschäft der anderen Leute kaputt zu machen.
Oder noch ein Anrufer, den Stefan. Hallo, Stefan aus Hameln. Du hast einen Einwurf.
Ja, ich hab einen Einwurf. Zum einen finde ich, machen die Leute einfach zu großen Hype um diese ganze Geschichte. Also jetzt diese Drossel-Geschichte, die wird da püttelig aufgeblasen, weil das anscheinend echt wahnsinnig schick ist, dagegen die Telekom zu schießen, weil es halt der Marktmachrimus da irgendwo ist.
Die Telekom war die Erste, die da einen Schritt nach vorne gemacht haben. Ich glaube, es hätte auch Oda vorhin oder Arthur oder sonst noch jemand getroffen, der gesagt hat, wir scheffen Flatrates ab und machen da Pakete draus.
Das stimmt nicht. Kabel Deutschland hat schon über einem Jahr Schwierigkeiten diesbezüglich und hat das Publik gemacht, dass die auch drosseln und war damit auch in der Presse.
Kabel Deutschland drosselt selektiv und nur an dem einen Tag.
Und Kabel Deutschland hat auch kein richtiges Leitungsmonopol in der gesamten Bundesrepublik auf alle Telefonanschlüsse.
Es ist aber auch, sag ich mal so in Einführungsstrichen, Kabel Deutschland ist auch ein ehemaliger Staatsminister, ist auch im Wohnraum der Bundeskost ausgegliedert. Und wie gesagt, diese Drossel-Geschichte, das ist definitiv nicht eine Erfindung der Telekom. Die will auch um die Telekom sprechen. Das Ding ist, die Leute regen sich jetzt alle so auf, aber wenn sie mal in ihre Verträge reingucken würden, die sie jetzt schon haben, dann würde ihnen auffallen, dass sie jetzt schon längst eine Drossel drin haben.
Zumindest, dass sie unterschrieben haben, dass gedrosselt werden darf.
Richtig, macht die Telekom aber noch nicht.
Macht die Telekom noch nicht. Und die Telekom hat auch gesagt, dass sie das wahrscheinlich erst ab 2016 überhaupt technisch auf die Reihe kriegen könnte. Und das Zweite ist, wie gesagt, dass in den Bestandsverträgen jetzt schon, in den aktuellen VDSL-Verträgen, da längst schon eine Drossel drin ist. Also von daher ist das definitiv jetzt eine Sache, die da so wahnsinnig hochgehängt wird.
Entschuldigung, sie ist jetzt halt vorhanden. Also da wird ja jetzt nicht irgendwie künstlich aufgebauscht, was vorher schon immer da war. Die Telekom hat halt gesagt...
Also du meinst die Pressemitteilung der Telekom?
Die Pressemitteilung der Telekom, das ist was...
Das wird den Leuten jetzt halt bewusst, dass das so ist.
Das wird den Leuten jetzt bewusst. Vor allen Dingen, es gibt jetzt auch was, worüber die Presse überhaupt berichten kann. Vorher gab es keinen Berichtsgegenstand. Also vorher gab es keine Nachricht. Und jetzt ist es nur Nachricht geworden. Und dann wird halt über eine Nachricht gesprochen. Also diese Kritik, die du anbringst, die kannst du bei jeder beliebigen Nachricht anbringen. Also jedes Thema, das in der Zeitung oder im Fernsehen diskutiert wird, wird dann nach diesen Kriterien künstlich aufgebauscht.
Für so eine Sache brauchst du immer zwei Bedingungen. Das ist ein Grund so. Also die Umstellung von Flattoil auf Volumen. Aber man braucht auch immer noch einen Anlass, damit Leute wirklich einen Punkt in der Zeit haben, wo sie kollektiv zu der Kenntnis kommen. Nee, das ist nicht so. Und die dann halt auch äußern. Und der Grund war natürlich schon länger da. Aber jetzt ist eben mit der Pressemitteilung von der Telekom der Anlass da, mal darauf hinzuweisen, dass das nicht so richtig das ist, was wir eigentlich wollen.
Was es ja auch gab, das war vor ein paar Jahren, gab es mal diese Fair Use Policy von 1 und 1, wo du auch eine Flatrate hattest. Wenn du dir aber immer schön Volllast gefahren hast, hast du irgendwann von denen Post gekriegt. Und die haben gesagt, hör mal auf damit, sonst schmeißen wir dich raus, mein Freund.
Auch schon lange, ja.
Echt?
Telekom ja auch schon ziemlich lange. Wenn du zum Beispiel im Bereich FNTP oder so was, wenn du da weißt, hier zu viel Spam über deinen Account laufen lässt, dann kriegst du auch eine Meldung von der Post.
Aber meinst du es auch inhaltlich, also findest du die Kritik auch inhaltlich überzogen oder stört dich, dass es sich jetzt so an der Telekom festmacht?
Mich stört einfach, dass da so ein Wahnsinnshype drum gemacht wird, dass das Ganze irgendwo, ja, wenn man jetzt mal wirklich die ganzen Provider mal nehmen würde und würde mal gucken, vom Vergleich her, wie es aussieht, von der Qualität her, dann weiß ich nicht, ob da jetzt das alles dieser Hype so gerecht ist.
Das Problem, welches ich mal ganz kurz hier sagen darf, das Problem ist, dass ich keinen nennenswerten Betrag die Telekom mehr koste, unabhängig davon, ob ich meine Leitungen ausnutze oder nicht. Das spielt für die keine Rolle, die haben dadurch keine Kosten, insbesondere weil sie ein so großer Anbieter sind.
Nein, sie haben keine Kosten. Das ist ihr Laden, das ist ein Wirtschaftsunternehmen, das interessanterweise auch noch immer in Bundesland gehört. Also das ist ja nicht so, dass das ein Privatunternehmen ist, wo die Mehrheitsanteilshalter entsprechend Privatpersonen sind.
Das ist eine Aktiengesellschaft heute.
Der Bund hat eine Sperrmigurität, also 15 Prozent oder so was.
Bleiben wir doch mal bei den Fakten. Kostet das die Telekom mehr, wenn ich 500 statt 50 Gigabyte im Monat durch die Leitungen blase? Frag ich jetzt mal Nibler, der weiß das.
Nee, das kostet die Telekom nicht mehr, aber sie haben natürlich schon nutzungsabhängig eine gewisse Grund, dass das Mittel sich trotzdem am Ende raus. Es spricht nichts dagegen zu sagen, wenn wir die Bandbreite nicht haben, dann kriegen die Leute, die Filesharing machen, ein bisschen weniger Filesharing. Da würde sich niemand aufregen. Das würde jeder von seinem Internetanschluss erwarten, dass zu Spitzenzeiten halt das ein oder andere Protokoll, auf das man verzichten kann, dank Netzwerkmanagement, ein bisschen langsamer ist man aber immer noch telefonieren kann. Das wäre die korrekteste Anwendung von Netzwerkmanagement. Da würden alle Kunden sich total noch in den Bauch freuen, weil sie ganz genau wissen, hey, das ist zwar gerade eng, weil Stoßzeit, aber mein Internet ist nicht funktionar kaputt. Ganz im Gegenteil, das funktioniert noch hervorragend. Und mein Anbieter kümmert sich darum, dass eben mit dem besten Effort das Netz zur Verfügung gestellt wird.
Das ist nämlich best effort.
Genau das heißt best effort. Und da hätte niemand was dagegen, wenn die Telekom sagten, ja das mit dem Ausbau, das wird schwierig, 100 Gigabit Interfaces sind teuer.
Vielleicht sollten wir andersrum denken.
Dann dürfen wir uns jetzt nicht darüber aufregen oder was?
Nein, wenn man die Kritik ernst nimmt, müsste man auch die anderen Anbieter jetzt sich mal ansehen und die Vertragsbedingungen, was ja auch einige Leute jetzt gerade tun, gerade so bei der Aufregung, und ein bisschen Vergleiche herstellen. Das heißt auch dort die Vertragsoptionen usw. durchsehen. Wäre denn das aus deiner Sicht fair? Würdest du dich da sozusagen zufriedener machen mit dem Streit um diese Drosselung? Ist er noch da?
Hallo?
Also findest du das fair?
Drei gegen ein oder vier gegen ein.
Ich hab die ganze Zeit nichts gesagt.
Aber es ist auch nicht gegen, ich denke mal nicht, dass das sowieso eigentlich eine Meinung ist.
Also du findest schon, dass es okay ist generell mal darüber zu sprechen, wann wer diskriminieren soll.
Also das ist klar. Ich denke, diese Nummer mit diesem Kleingedruckten, ich denke, das ist so die Sache, dass das Kleingedruckte sollte endlich mal ein bisschen publik gemacht werden. Und ich denke, das, wo einem die Augen dann wehtun, wenn man irgendwelche Prospekte liest, wo man dann denken muss, dass ihnen die Tinte ausgegangen ist, dunkelgrau auf hellgrau auf weiß, da muss man auch sparen wegen der Volumen oder auch ganz modernen Sachen. Das kann es eher wenig sein. Da sind sie alle gut. Wie sie da sind, da kannst du alle in einen Sack packen und draufkloppen. Da ist keiner von denen besser.
Ich wollte dir nur noch einen kurzen Hinweis liefern. Du hast gerade eingangs erwähnt, dass auch heute schon eine Drossel-Klausel in den Verträgen besteht. Die bezieht sich aber auf eine 6M mit Drossel. Das ist zu wenig, um dir den Spaß am Internet zu nehmen. Und damit zu wenig, um dich zu motivieren, dann nochmal ein Paket zu kaufen oder sogar dann monatlich auf den höheren Tarif zu gehen. Das wäre das schönste dann für mich.
Da verweist die Telekom sozusagen versehentlich, wo denn wirklich ihre Schmerzgrenze ist. Also, dass sie 6M mit auf jeden Fall liefern können. Und das ist, was sie einem dazu gestehen in so einem Fall.
Was meint die Telekom damit, wenn sie sagt, alte Verträge sind davon nicht betroffen? Der Vertrag, den ich mit denen seit anderthalb Jahren habe, ist legal.
Also, da habe ich weiter. Da wollen sie, dass du den bloß nicht kündigst und zu einem anderen Anbieter gehst.
Ja, das ist das eine.
Bis die anderen Anbieter auch drosseln, dann drosseln sie meinen auch.
Ich meine, die sind sehr schwer behäbig da bei der Telekom. Die sind definitiv nicht flexibel, sind sie nicht. Das ist ja das Manko. Die könnten erheblich mehr wahrscheinlich. Und ich sag mal so, ich will auch mal jetzt eine Bresche schlagen für die Leute von der Telekom. Die machen, denke ich, mir einen relativ guten Job, wenn ich mir angucke, was die für ein Netz da aufrechterhalten in Deutschland.
Wer hat denn das gebaut? Hat die Telekom noch nicht gebaut?
Naja, der Punkt ist...
Nein, nein, Moment. Das geht jetzt gar nicht um Telekom oder wer das gebaut hat, sondern ich sag mal so, die Frage ist, wenn ein anderer Anbieter das hätte, ob der das genauso gemanagt kriegen würde oder so.
Ich muss auch mal eine Anzeige mit der Telekom brechen. Sie haben IPv6 momentan, sind sie am Ausrollen, also du kriegst an vielen, vielen Stellen in ihrer Netz, das ist zwar auch irgendwie ein Jahrzehnt überfällig, aber immerhin.
Das ist doch wie mit dem Wahlbürger und dem Kunden. Ich meine, die Leute, die bei der Telekom arbeiten, die kuckleleute und die Techniker, die können noch nichts für ihre Unternehmensspitze. Das ist wie unsere Regierung, die haben auch nicht gewählt.
Das ist eine Handvoll Leute, die das Scheiße baut.
Nein, das ist natürlich eine politische Entscheidung des Unternehmens nach ihrem Geschäftsmodell.
Und was ich mir auch mal so angucke ist, es gibt in vielen Gebieten zum Beispiel hier Schaltstellen, die erheblich mehr könnten. Ja, vom Ausbau. Da könnte VLSL locker laufen mit 30, 40 Mbit oder sowas und die schalten sie einfach nicht frei. Ich sag mal so jetzt gerade bei uns zum Beispiel in Hameln. Hameln hat fürchterlich damals schwer getan mit DSL, weil in Hameln fürchterlich viel Glasfaser in die Erde gekloppt worden ist. Von wegen, ah, Hype und so, wir knallen jetzt Glasfaser in die Erde und dann hatten sie das Problem, dass wir kein DSL legen konnten, weil sie mit der letzten Meilen Probleme hatten.
Das Opalgetto eben hab ich auch gesehen.
Weil sie dann nämlich diese De-Slams da nicht weit an die Straße gekriegt haben. Was haben sie dann gemacht? Haben sie auf jedem Verteilerkasten so einen extra Kasten oben draufgebaut und haben in Wirklichkeit einen Schritt wieder zurück gemacht. Anstatt den Leuten wirklich Firebird Home auf den Tisch zu legen und zu sagen, hier Leute, wir sind immer innovativ und wir legen euch jetzt hier meinetwegen 100 MBit, ein Gasfaserport legen wir euch da an die Tür rein. Was dann nicht mehr so ganz das Thema gewesen wäre. Ich hab echt manchmal das Gefühl, dass die wirklich Angst haben, so viel Bandbreite dahin zu legen, weil sie da irgendwie dann sozusagen so ein großes Fass aufmachen, wo sie nachher zubuttern müssen. Dass die wirklich konservativ da ihre Bandbreiten ausbauen, weil sie Angst haben, dass sie da berumpelt werden von den ganzen bösen, bösen Pfeilscherern und von den ganz bösen Saugern und Litern und wie sie alle heißen und da irgendwie nachher für die internationalen Netze, wo sie auch reinspeisen müssen.
Ja, aber die Netzübergänge und das Backbone sind nicht problematisch.
Punkt!
Da ist kein Engpass.
Hey, klar, kein Problem.
Ihr Chaosradio 189 geht natürlich um die Telekom und ihre Drosselungen. Nach den Nachrichten geht es da weiter drum.
Live und neu und gut. Live im Privatklub. Wann genau und wo genau?
Fritze.
Iswels, MC Fitti und Lindsay Stirling. Live und neu und gut empfohlen von Fritz.
Und das hört man um kurz in halb zwölf.
Die Betreiber des künftigen Flughafens BER in Schönefeld müssen die Anwohner besser vor Fluglärm schützen als bisher geplant. Das entschied das Oberverwaltungsgericht Berlin Brandenburg am Abend. Weil das Schallschutzprogramm des Flughafens zu klein bemessen ist, kommen auf den Flughafen jetzt mehr Kosten in Höhe von rund 300 Millionen Euro zu. In dem Verfahren ging es darum, ob Fluglärm tagsüber die normale Gesprächslautsstärke von 55 Dezibel in den 14.000 betroffenen Wohnungen überschreiten darf. Jetzt hab ich das Bett ausgemacht.
Das war ich.
Ja, weil ich ein bisschen zu früh dran war, aber ich hab noch ein paar Nachrichten. Ja, eigentlich hättest du das machen sollen. Ja, hast du ja auch. Ich hab's.
Ich hab's.
Lassen wir's. Ich hab's überhaupt nicht verloren. Ich mach weiter. Mach mal weiter. Die Bundesregierung hat sich bei UN-Menschenrechtsrat für die Ermittlungsfehler zur rechtsextremen Terrorgruppe NSU entschuldigt. Der Menschenrechtsbeauftragte der Bundesregierung Löhning sagte in Genf, die Mordserie gehöre zweifellos zu den schlimmsten Menschenrechtsverletzungen in Deutschland in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten. Die Vereinten Nationen mahnten, Deutschland müsse noch mehr gegen Rassismus tun. Die mutmaßlichen Attentäter von Boston sollen auch einen Anschlag auf den Times Square in New York geplant haben. Bürgermeister Bloomberg sagte dies habe ihm die Bundespolizei FBI mitgeteilt. Die beiden Brüder hatten dafür bereits Bomben gebaut. Zuvor waren neue Ermittlungspannen bekannt geworden. Neben dem FBI soll auch der Geheimdienst CIA schon 2011 von russischen Behörden über die mutmaßlichen Täter informiert worden sein. Zu Konsequenzen kam es aber nicht, möglicherweise wegen unterschiedlicher Schreibweisen der Namen der aus Tschetschenien stammenden Männer. Vor der Küste Westafrikas ist ein Schiff einer Hamburger Reederei von Piraten angegriffen worden. Sie haben vier Besatzungsmitglieder als Geiseln genommen. Das bestätigte die Reederei. Das Containerschiff ist demnach schon am Montag angegriffen worden und konnte seine Reise Richtung Senegal fortsetzen. Die betroffenen Crewmitglieder kommen aus der Ukraine, Russland und Kiribati. Um die Entführten nicht zu gefährden, will die Reederei keine weiteren Details bekannt geben. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen. In Berlin-Köpenik haben wir es 12, in Charlottenburg 16 Grad. Forst meldet 10, Eberswalde 13, Potsdam 16 und Wittenberge 17 Grad. In der Nacht kühlt es auf 13 bis 9 Grad ab, teilweise ist es bewölkt, Schauer sind aber nur selten möglich. Morgen zeigt sich dann erst die Sonne, später ziehen dichtere Wolken heran und neben Regen gibt es örtlich auch Gewitter bei maximal 18 Grad an der Dosse und 26 Grad an der Neiße. Stadtverkehr Berlin, A100, Startring Richtung Neukölln zwischen Hohenzollern, Damm und Tintunnel, Innsbrucker Platz ist wegen einer Baustelle die linke Spur gesperrt. A113, Zubringer Schönefeld statt einwärts zwischen Schönefeld Nord und Adlershof gibt es eine Vollsperrung wegen Wartungsarbeiten, das ganze dauert noch bis 5 Uhr früh. Und auf der AWUS A115 sind die Auf- und Abfahrtenhüttenweg bis Ende Mai in beiden Richtungen gesperrt, gesperrt ist außerdem der Hüttenweg unter der Warnbrücke. Nach Brandenburg A20 Rostock Richtung Kreuz Uckermark zwischen Parsevalg Süd und Prenzlau Ost gab es einen Unfall und die rechte Spur ist blockiert. Wir wünschen euch wie immer überall wo es geht eine gute Fahrt.
Danke Jonte, 8 Minuten nach E12.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Danke fürs Zuschauen. Wir sind immer noch bei der Telekom und ihrer Drosselung.
Wir sollten vielleicht mal kurz zusammenfassen, was der etwas abgewirkte Stefan kurz vor den Nachrichten noch gesagt hat. Also glaube die die Forderung, die da so durchschien, war ja eine bessere Transparenz vor den Kunden. Also er hat sich ja so ein bisschen auch dann darüber beklagt, dass man die Vertragskondition nicht mehr lesen kann.
Ja, das ist überhaupt dieser ganze Umgang, den dieses Unternehmen dann auch mit seinen Kunden antagelegt. Mir ist völlig klar, dass sie das machen, um irgendwie Kohle zu verdienen, aber die verkaufen mich für dumm. Also weißt du, die halten mich für einen Idioten in ihrer Pressemeldung. Das ist das, was mich so aufregt. Meinetwegen kommt vorbeisagt, so Holgi, wenn du jetzt dein VDSL behalten willst, dann zahlst du jetzt mal 15 Euro mehr jeden Monat. Hast du jetzt davon, wir sind nämlich Monopolist. Dann sag ich im Zweifel, ach Arschloch, naja, hier hast du das Geld. Aber wenn da einer kommt und sagt, ich halte dich für doof und darum sorge ich jetzt dafür, dass du mir 15 Euro gibst, das trägt mich so auf.
Ja, ist die Polemik jetzt wieder zurück in unserer schönen sachlichen Sendung.
Entschuldigung, das trägt mich so auf.
Na ja, ich glaube, was hättest du denn gern? Möchtest du gerne so eine Art von Transparenz gegenüber dir als Kunden, die sagt, also Internet gibt es bei uns für diesen Preis, aber nur gedrosselt so und so. Wie genau hättest du denn gern, dass das auch jeder versteht?
Dass sie mich nicht verarschen, dass sie einfach nur sagen, wir haben uns überlegt, wir ändern jetzt unser Geschäftsmodell.
Das mit den Flatroids ist jetzt nicht mehr, wir machen jetzt nur noch Volumenpakete.
Weil wir das wollen oder weil wir können.
Wie wäre denn mit transparenten Modellrechnungen? Sie legen dir zum Beispiel vor, also in diesem und jedem Nutzungsverhalten im Schnitt werden sie so und so. Also könnte man sich ja auch vorstellen aus Transparenz gründen. Modellrechnungen. Also wahrscheinlich haben jetzt alle mal auf Drossel geklickt, oder?
Drossel.de? Drossel.de? Drossel, ohne das E, D-E. Da hat Sebastian Vollenhals eine schöne Seite gebaut, wo man für jeden einzelnen Tarif dann genau sehen kann, was ich da finde, wie lange man tatsächlich mit voller Geschwindigkeit surfen kann. Das ist dann so ein Stundenbereich oder so, ich habe gerade kein Netz. Stunden bis vielleicht maximal ein Tagesbereich, wenn man so mit 50 MBit daher surft. Und gleichzeitig hat er dann ausgerechnet, wie viel Internet man maximal nutzen kann, wenn man dann noch die restlichen 30 Tage mit 384 Kb da Vollgas gibt.
Und er hat ja nicht auch ein Video gemacht, der hat auch das Video gemacht, wo man die Telekom Seite sieht, wie sie lädt, wenn die Drossel an ist.
Wenn die Drossel an ist und das ist irgendwie anderthalb Minuten oder so quälendes Video. Das ist ganz schlimm, aber das ist guter Mann und gute Seite.
Stell dir mal vor, du hast einen Tippfehler drin und das ist erst mal die Navigationshilfe.
Wir sind ja schon ein bisschen bei Aktionismus angekommen. Jetzt sieht man schon, dass es nicht so viele Kreative sind, dass sie sich auch damit auseinandersetzen. Also wie zum Beispiel Drossel. Wir wollen mal ein bisschen darüber reden, was soll ich machen?
Ich habe hier das Wort noch stehen auf meinem Zettel, das heißt Gegenmaßnahmen. Genau, was machen wir denn da eigentlich? Wir haben übrigens jetzt ganz viele Anrufer noch.
Kündigt euer Spotify-Paket, zeigt der Telekom, dass er so zusatzbedingte Scheiße findet.
Die Idee ist tatsächlich aus mehreren Blogs, die jetzt darüber geschrieben haben, die haben gesagt, sie finden eigentlich schön den Service, aber sie unterstützen es nicht mehr und werden ihr Geld jetzt direkt Spotify geben und nicht mehr bei der Telekom. Und das ist auch etwas, was die Telekom als eine Art Kunden-Protest merken würde. Das könnte man... Genau, und ein direktes Feedback bekommen, während die Verträge ja in der Regel sehr langfristig laufen und Eidverträge ja ohnehin nicht betroffen sind. Insofern ist eine Protestform, fand ich interessant, dass man auch einfach sagt, okay, den Anbieter will ich eigentlich weiter haben. Ich bin aber bereit, da sozusagen wieder hinzuwechseln und nicht den Telekom zu zahlen. Eine andere Sache, die wir gerne als Aktionsform hier mal kurz ankündigen wollten, wäre verbunden mit der Hauptversammlung der Telekom, die ja demnächst sein wird. Und wir wollten mal fragen, ob es Aktionäre unter unseren Hörern gibt, die bereit sind, ihr Recht, Stimmrecht, oder? das Recht überhaupt zur Hauptversammlung zu gehen, abzudrehen.
Das ist relativ einfach. Man bekommt ja die Einladung. Die kam jetzt gerade raus, die Hauptversammlung selber ist am 16. Mai in Köln. Und bis Anfang Mai muss man quasi Leute bevollmächtigt haben. Und dann dürfen die dahin.
Ich hab leider keine, obwohl ich ja neulich erfahren habe, dass die Dividenden steuerfrei sind. Was ja schon mal ganz nett ist.
Die auch keine Höhenessteuer?
Ich lass die Dividenden direkt auf mein Schweizer Konto überweisen.
Man muss auch dazu sagen, dass die Idee nicht von uns kommt, sondern das haben aktiv Leute angesprochen. Wir haben da Sturmrecht auf, weil wir Telekom-Aktien haben. Tolle Idee.
Da würden wir vielleicht auch mal kurz, also wir hätten da auch mal eine Mail-Adresse, wo man sich hinwenden kann.
Du, Konstanze, habt ihr eigentlich auch eine Mail-Adresse, an die man sich wenden kann, wenn man euch zuhause sorgt?
Mail-ad-cc.de empfehlen, oder?
Info-ad-digitalegesellschaft.de Wird ausgeschrieben, habt ihr auch die gestern, oder habt ihr nur digitale Gesellschaft?
Info-ad, nee, Mail-ad-cc.de.
Wir klären das dann, also wir machen da round robin.
Ich möchte darauf hinweisen, dass das eine Adresse ist, die mehrere Leute lesen, also keine allzu privaten Personen, aber eine Kontaktmöglichkeit wäre schön.
Ja, wundervoll. Der Gregor aus Darmstadt hat angerufen. Hallo Gregor. Du hast dich bei der Telekom beschwert.
Ja.
Was haben sie gesagt?
Viele komische Dinge. Also es hat ja damit angefangen, dass ich da so ein bisschen Vitamin B zur Telekom habe und dass man mir da irgendwie schon im Januar gesteckt hat, dass da was kommt.
Hast du dieses Gerücht im Internet gestreut?
Gregor war es.
Das habe ich so unter der Hand bekommen und da habe ich auch gesagt, von dir wisst das auch nicht. Also die Telekom, möchte ich auch nochmal zu meinem Vorredner sagen, macht viel mit. Zum Beispiel das ATV6, das ihr angesprochen habt, das macht sie nur an IP-Anschlüssen. ISDN bis 2016, Grundversorger in Deutschland, irgendwie gesetzlich festgeschrieben oder so. Da war mal kein IPv6, nee.
Hat einen technischen Grund, das wollen sie da einfach nicht mehr bauen, weil das ganz fürchterlich schlimm supportet ist, noch von den Herstellern. Das war schon bei DSL ein echter Kampf, das hinzukriegen.
Und sie haben wahrscheinlich ein paar die entschiedenen Ressourcen.
Die machen auf Anschlüsse, wo ISDN noch dran ist, kein IPv6.
Hab ich anderes gesehen. Also ich kenne mindestens einen Telekom Anschluss, das ist ADSA direkt am HVT mit IPv6 und ISDN aus der S12 oder aus der ISD.
Definitiv.
Du hast gerade mehr Akronyme gesagt als Konjunktionen.
Ich kenne den ASB nicht, aber es ist in Nürnberg.
Was ich noch empfehlen kann für die Hörer ist diese Tim-Pritzloff-Serie Chaosradio Express. Hat man bestimmt schon gehört. Da ist Clemens Shrimp auch dabei und macht sich fürchterlich über die Telekom her.
Kennt er dich?
In diversen Folgen.
Hast du mal einen Song gehört? Hast du den gehört?
Nein, leider nicht. Ich hab erst etwas später zuschalten können. Ich war unterwegs. Und auch Logbuchnetzpolitik von Tim-Pritzloff hat sich jetzt auch schon über die Telekom hergemacht.
Ich bin da der Co-Moderator.
Wer ist mich da? Wo kommt die Stimme her? Den kenne ich irgendwo her.
Also was ich auch von der Telekom direkt gehört habe, ist, als ich das nämlich gelesen habe auf IZD, habe ich da gerade angerufen und gesagt, jetzt mache ich Dampf. Dann hat mir gesagt, Telekom Partner, VideoLoad oder Spotify, die Namen sind explizit gefallen, werden gar nicht erst in diese Drossel reingenommen. Der hat quasi schon offen gestanden Nachrichtssprache mit seinen Vorgesetzten. Nö, so Netz-Neutralität brauchen wir nicht.
Haben die dir zu verstehen gegeben, ob da schon andere vor dir angerufen hatten?
Ich war wohl mit einer der ersten.
Ah, ok, da warst du gleich gelesen und zum Telefonhörer gegriffen.
Ja, ich hab's auch erst nicht von Heisede gekriegt, sondern von so einer Apple-seitigen News-Webseite und dann gleich angerufen, was überhaupt auf den großen Seiten stand. Und auch auf die Frage hin, was sie sich denn überhaupt denken, wenn ich irgendwie, ich muss ja mit meinem DSL 6000-Ramm-Tarif, den sie mir da verkaufen, muss ich mich, kann ich nicht mal meine ganze Amtesteam-Libriothek herunterladen? Und er meint ja, Pech. Ja genau, ich gehe in die Straße an der LV, sie sollen mir eine DVD brennen. Das müsste billiger sein als die Pakistaner von der Telekom.
Was wäre denn, du sagst deine, du hast ja quasi was getan, nämlich da angerufen, hättest du Ideen vom britischem Aktivismus, was man dagegen unternehmen könnte?
Es gab ein schönes Beispiel in den Niederlanden, wo eine holländische Mobilfunkagentur da gesagt hat, WhatsApp macht uns das Geschäftsmodell kaputt und haben da fix mal den Port gesperrt. Dann haben die Holländer aber ganz schnell beschlossen, Netzneutralität gesetzlich zu machen.
Also du wirst einen Gesetzgeber appellieren wollen, naja, das sieht ja nicht so gut aus.
Also mit dem deutschen Gesetzgeber habe ich es jetzt nicht so sehr. Aber ich denke, wenn man zu Anbietern geht, die das im Moment noch nicht machen würden, würde das einen Zeichen setzen. Wenn aber die Telekom da mit Anstandsfluss durchkommt oder es zumindest so weit verschleppt, dass dieser Shitstorm, der gerade am Kochen ist, abklingt, dann haben sie gewonnen.
Na gut, das sind jetzt zwar nicht so die Top-Tipps, aber die müssen wir mal hinnehmen.
Gregor, schönen Dank für deinen Anruf. Ich habe hier noch einen prominenten Anrufer in der Leitung hängen. Kennt ihr den? Kennt ihr den? Namen Clemens. Echt? Clemens ist der Sänger von Funktional kaputt. Das Lied, das wir hier hören.
Ich habe noch eine schöne Idee gerade zu dem Vorredner. Das habe ich nämlich auch schon gehört, dass die Telekom sagt, oh ja, unsere Partner. Machen einen Vorschlag für den CCC. Ruft doch mal bei der Telekom an und sagt, hallo, wir haben ja auch eine tolle Webseite, wir haben auch die schönen Videos vom Kongress und so. Wir würden gerne Partner bei euch werden. Das ist so eine richtig schöne Hosen runter Nummer, weil entweder die Telekom sagt, nee, mit euch nicht, dann hat man natürlich ein geiles politisches Pfand in der Hand, dass man sagt, also nicht nur verletzen sie Netzneutralität, sondern auch noch die Leute, die bei ihnen was bezahlen wollen, suchen sie auch noch danach aus, was ihnen gefällt, oder wie ihnen sozusagen die Attitüde, die ihnen gefällt. Und wenn sie das nicht machen, dann müssen sie zumindest mal eine Zahl nennen, dann weiß man zumindest mal, was die Telekom vom TTC haben wollen würde, dafür, dass sie euch nicht prostet.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das kann man einfach mal machen, oder könnte auch Tim machen, aber wie gesagt, das TTC macht sich noch ein bisschen cooler.
Ich werde den Vorschlag gerne mal überdenken, möglicherweise werde ich den Beschluss der Mitgliedersversammlung ja beiführen müssen.
Wir machen hier so ein Internetradio.
Wir reden davon ja zumindest Gigabyte, klar, wenn man einfach an die Kongressfilme und so weiter denkt.
Ihr seid ja da richtig Content-Anbieter und da kann man den ja mal auf den Tisch legen. Das ist eine schöne Hosen runter Aktion, da müssen wir echt mal Farbe bekennen.
Möchtest du noch weitere Songs eigentlich zur Verfügung stellen?
Das musst du David fragen. Ich bin echt vollkommen schockiert. Die Leute twittern mir, dass diese Nummer jetzt in die Platzsäcke. Weil die einfach großartig ist.
Du bist sogar schon im Radio gelaufen.
Ja, leider war ich da noch nicht zu Hause.
Aber du hast wahrscheinlich schon gehört, dass du im Radio warst.
Das ist einfach kraftvoll. Wie sagt man.
Das ist einfach kaputt. Das ist nicht gedrossen.
Also dein Antwort, von der ist die Sendung rund gemacht. Technisch mein Fahrt mal rein. Aber offensichtlich hat er ja nette Probleme. Vielleicht ist er ja schon gedrosselt. Oder er ist ein armer E-Plus-Kunde. Also man weiß gar nicht. Die Telekom nutzt ja derzeit in dem Endkunden-Backbone maximal 60 Prozent. Kann man natürlich ganz einfach ausrechnen, weil alles jenseits des DSL-Anschlusses, also jenseits der letzten Meile, ist ja symmetrisch gebaut. Das heißt, du hast dann zwar deine 50.10 beim VDSL-Anschluss, 50.10 mit Download, 10.10 mit Upload.
Wo du auch eigentlich nicht 50.10 hast, sondern 125.
Ich habe es ja neulich mal gemacht. Ich habe es ja mal mit einem befreiten Wiflama, eine Fritzbox dran, eine ganz normale Fritzbox dran gehängt. Ich glaube bei einem Sender der Fritz heißt, darf man auch mal eine Fritzbox erwähnen.
Ja, ja, du hast es zweimal genannt, wir haben es gehört.
Ich muss mal sagen, ich habe einen handelsüblichen DSL-Router genommen und den war in einem befreiten Wiflama dran gefahren und der hat dann einfach mal 102 Megabit Download und 64 Megabit Upload gemacht. Aber darum geht es mir gar nicht. Die Infrastruktur dahinter, die die Telekom ja schon alles bezahlt hat, ist komplett symmetrisch. Die haben ja ihr Gigabit-Internet und das bauen sie nicht asymmetrisch.
Wir hatten das ganz am Anfang schon, im Backbauen ist ein Kapazitätsengpest auch einfach nicht da. Das bestätigen die sogar. Ich hatte das ganz am Anfang erwähnt. Der Bundestag hat die deutschen Provider einfach mal gefragt. Und dabei kam das klar raus.
Aber da können sie jetzt ohne auch nur für eine halbe Patchkabel bezahlen, sie müssen sozusagen noch Volumen frei machen. Wenn jetzt die Telekom ohnehin sagt, wir rechnen ja ganz, wir sind ja total fair jetzt, wir rechnen jetzt Volumenbasiert ab. Dann können sie auch endlich den Stock aus dem Arsch oder aus der Leitung nehmen und sagen, ja, machen wir mal hier mal den Upload auf. Weil es wird ja eh fair volumenmäßig abgerechnet. Und die Kapazität ist da, ohne dass sie auch nur eine Schraube kaufen müssen.
Ich glaube, wünschen würden sich das viele, für wie realistisch er jetzt ist. Also das ist ja nicht sehr realistisch.
Natürlich nicht, weil es ist jetzt auch so ein vorgeschrömmertes Ding, wo man sich mal wieder an den Haaren ziehen kann und sagen, hier, euer Argument ist eigentlich vollkommen aus der Luft gegriffen.
Oh, sag mal nochmal, dann können wir daraus einen Song machen. Bei dem Upload betrifft das würden sich sicherlich viele wünschen, klar.
Ja, sehr, sehr viele. Die ganzen freischaffenden Leute, Fotografen, das sind nicht alle. Auch, wie ist denn die jetzt anfangen, plötzlich Online-Backup zu machen? Das weiß ich jetzt nicht aus technischer Sicht, aber zumindest könnten sie dann.
Und glaubst du denn, dass uns Rösler und Eigener retten werden?
Also ich hab gehört, dass die SPD sich halt gesagt hat, ja klar, die SPD, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, wer uns zuerst retten wird, oder? Es gibt ja so eine Forderung, dass man die Bundesnetzagentur da aufwerten will, dass die also besser reguliert und sich anders einsetzt. Hältst du davon was?
Ich halte davon sehr viel, weil momentan weiß ich nicht, wofür sich die ganzen Beamten da, die den Hintern gerade platz sitzen. Die regulieren ja mehr, da bin ja nur Telefonie und das auch nur im Festnetz.
Den Interconnect-Preis und so weiter.
Aber nicht zum Entkunden.
Richtig.
Da passen sie nicht auf, was da gemacht wird. Und es wäre wohl hin mal gut, wenn zum Beispiel, das war ja vorhin schon angeschnitten worden, da habe ich euch dann schon zugehört, dass man mal aufhört die Leute zu verarschen. Mit irgendwelchen Flatrates, die keine sind und so weiter und so fort dran.
Ich bin angeblich, dass nur Flatrate heißt, was Flatrate-Ding sind, dass du dir irgendwie dein 5 Gigabyte-Paket im Mobilfunknetz buchen kannst. Das ist alles schön und gut. Aber das Flatrate zu nennen ist einfach eine Frechheit.
Und damit kommen wir zum Ende der heutigen Sendung. Nein.
Das wird aber ein kurzer Song.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Wir hätten noch einen kleinen Aufruf, der... Bitte. Ja, der ZZC ist auf der Suche nach jemandem. Es gab eine Entscheidung des Sächsischen Oberlandesgerichtes zu biometrieren Reisepassen. Und wir würden den Kläger bitten, sich beim ZZC zu melden.
Steht das nicht im Urteil, wie der Kläger heißt?
Das ist kein Urteil. Dem steht der Rechtsweg jetzt offen. Das hat die OEG gesagt. Und wir würden gern Kontakt zu dem...
Erklär noch mal, worum geht's?
Also jemand wehrt sich dagegen, dass die Fingerabdrücke in den Reisepass aufgenommen werden. Das ist ja auch auf anderen Rechtswegen geschehen. Und da gab es jetzt gerade eine Entscheidung des Sächsischen OEG. Also das wurde zugelassen hat, dass man überhaupt darüber verhandelt. Ja, genau. Und wir hätten halt gerne zu diesem Kläger Kontakt und würden ihn bitten, falls er gerade zuhört, biometrie... Bitte melde dich. biometrie.ccc.de Da würden wir uns freuen. Das ist jetzt aber wirklich das letzte, was ich ansagen wollte.
Vielen Dank, Constanze. Vielen Dank, Nibbler. Das war Chaosradio 189. Das nächste Chaosradio, nämlich Chaosradio 190, gibt's am letzten Donnerstag im Mai.
Der schöne Mai.
Der schöne Mai. Und jetzt gehen wir nach Hause.
Schönen Gruß an die Lille Lande.